Hey resume enough to check king h1 and
then what
yeah there's nothing there's nothing
there's no Queen takes Queen rook takes
h3 no Queen in green guards h4 bleonard
know he sees work f4 but rook makes
sword you miss Queens except for
negative six check puzzle rush me oh my
gosh that would have been nasty I will
show it as soon as the game is over
don't go anywhere
there was puzzle rush meet there there
may still be some sort of puzzle rush
you miss Queenie one there and we are
about to have liftoff here as Grand
Master Wei Yi and Grand Master pregnant
Anna gets set to throw down here the
games have begun shout out real quick
two lashes IQ who is super Grand Master
from Russia yonder pom Neha she hanging
out with us in the twitch TV chat
congratulations to him for winning the
first feat a Grand Prix of the of the
cycle of the defeated Grand Prix cycle
right there the the match is underway
and again thank you to everybody who's
with us regardless of where you're
choosing to tune in from today but the
the match is underway okay we've got an
English right we've got a focused way Yi
a focused prog hear your thoughts Robert
yeah I'm actually very curious how his
first game will go because probably nan
de with the black pieces anyone playing
blackens but he has to be very careful
and way he's best ever win I'll never
forget it seared into my mind his win
over Lazaro bruise on I don't even
determine those from 2015 he's the game
of a game immortal game the moment it
was played oh absolutely everyone was
you know the talk of the world and he is
such a fantastic player he's special
fantastic in attacking positions but
here we'll have more of a positional
grind because let's move Bishop b5 check
knight c6
at any moment white can play Bishop
takes c6 and challenge the Queen side
pawn structure and d4 means that okay I
have to take on before you could take
back with the night as was just played
and now you're gonna keep the isolated
pawn so it was it's a meadow stop matter
of style excuse me and at some points
waiking played Bishop takes c6 China
would put his rook on c1 and then take
over the c5 awesome that's what I was
highlighting as you were talking with
that was also the idea of maybe bringing
the bishop back to e2 to f3 this is this
is very much like a reversed sort of
caro-kann right or not a reversed but a
structure very similar to what you would
see in a Carroll Khan yeah absolutely
and the I guess the difference between a
carrot con this one is the missing epon
and the isolated D pawn for black but
yes you're absolutely right Dani and I
would say right now for Prague it's a
moment where he's taking quite a bit of
time in this movie there's 28 seconds
and well Bishop e6 interesting decision
here a deal of course protect the d5
pawn but also allow this pins a queen a4
is the first move that comes to my mind
you know great for kind of forces
Black's handle playing a queen e6 e7
maneuver and then what you just Castle
bugs
Queen Queen d7 may be met by something
like 95 right and and Queen d6 I think
even there there's still pressure coming
because 94 it's gonna be hard for black
to deal with this c6 pressure here
notice that way you just just gets
castled though decides he doesn't want
to be all in on the c6 tactic yesterday
that might allow Prague to develop
quickly in Castle ya know which is very
needed when there's you can low on the
camera over there he is getting low on
the camera there I'm watching their
connection and one of these one of the
factors we always think about in this
features championship is that these guys
are calling in from China and India
respectively and you wonder if sometimes
their their connection will be will be a
factor in the match we see that way e
their love a is rockin rockin a 3 bar
connection prog though super stable
though that's something to keep an eye
on I know that's not really chests but
it is one of the elements we always keep
track of here in regards to what happens
in time scrambles and things so alright
this should be - speaking of playing in
Chinese
past midnight there right now it is it
is past midnight but it's also past
10:00 p.m. and given that Prague is the
youngster in India I don't know who has
more of a disadvantage there right
playing you know midnight to 3:00 a.m.
or playing 10:00 a.m. 10:00 p.m. to 1
a.m. for Prague I don't know we'll see
hopefully everybody got there napping I
know I did
I got a nap in yesterday so I'm feeling
really
I feel good today you're looking refresh
you look about 10 years younger without
that beard I don't recognize myself
actually I might look at the broadcast
like who's that dude over well this is
okay so talking about the structure here
Robert you highlighted that black has
the isolated pawn which of course is a
weakness if white can can build up on it
and get all the coordination but right
now I mean black has active development
you're usually looking for activity on
the kingside if you can get it I wonder
I wonder what Prague is is considering
here because one of the tactics you
highlighted or one of the common themes
of the position is if black make some
random move let's say sometimes you'll
see a capture on c6 and a knight come to
a4 followed by a rook to c1 and what
happens here is that all the dark
squares become completely clamped by
white and black is just positionally
worse for the rest of the game so is
there you know decision going on here
for Prague to think about whether he D
whether he's gonna allow that because
obviously he would get the bishop Harris
compensation or whether he's considering
maybe moving the knight from c6 or
protecting it to avoid that structure
yeah it's a very different decision
honestly and the real question is does
can black buy a six in the initial
position because if you play a six
you're forcing White's hand to either
retreat with Bishop d3 which was a fine
move or six and it's a moot point now
because rook state was played but still
that's a very interesting point of
discussion where if is black gonna take
his beep-beep on to c6 and then deal
with his back up on pushing to c5 he was
a Knight to e4 later and get me on the
open files so I'll say to everybody
who's with us now if this type of
approach remains for both players today
we're gonna be in for a super
instructive speech Chess Championship
match here regardless of who wins
because there's a lot of just positional
nuggets and things that you can learn
about dynamic structures like this right
Robert where both sides are essentially
playing for different things Black has a
weakness but has activity and right now
let's just point out an obvious tactic
white cannot take twice on d5 everybody
because if you do you lose the lady at
the end of that line with a very
important and well-known theme that you
need to know discovered checks there so
Bishop c4 I kind of like that move even
if it doesn't work tactically Robert cuz
you're saying I'm gonna be aggressive
that's how you really justify an
isolated pawn weakness everyone is you
get activity Uncle Yermo always said the
best iqp isolated
quaint pond is one with no defense
because it means it's still on the board
and it means you've gotten enough
activity that they haven't had time to
take it so that's kind of just like a
philosophical thing to implant in your
brain and that's why I move like Bishop
c4 neglecting defense of the pawn has
been played here so I always knew Yermo
was very wise but especially here that
makes a lot of sense and when he
organized a pawn you think about the
adjacent files right you and rice on a D
file which means you've an open sea in
an open E file and that's why you make a
move like Bishop to be a try than any
bishop c7 because bishops he said would
close that rook off and you'll see a
like a very standard plan rook to e8 to
take over that semi-open efile being
Queen to d6 right now might be a good
time for that to threaten Czech minion
what I was just highlighting that you
know how I feel about threatening
checkmate I also feel like given that
fans a shout out again reminder to all
of you if you're joining us from chess
calm right now you might be watching us
at just the chest comm homepage the
chess your chest calm homepage and that
new little embed we have there give us a
click through and give our twitch
channel where the world's biggest events
for chess take place right here on
twitch.tv slash chess and give us a give
us a follow there so that you you know
where and when we're broadcasting in the
future also shout out to everyone at
chess TV and twitch.tv slash chess I see
you I see you peeps alright
I'm liking the way Prague's playing this
and I when I look at time that's also a
factor that's indicative of how maybe
confident the young man feels right
against against the favorite here Wei Yi
he's not really that far down on the
clock
we know he's g7 is that he missed that
tactic well I guess he's trying to
counter what nobody to now so he just
miss it I think he just missed it well
unfortunate timing here as we bring up
our kind of get to know you card Ramesh
Babu Pradhan andhe is from India his
feeded rating is 25 36 he's junior
ranking in the world is number 38 but
for how young he is he's 15 years old
that's pretty good
his interests are travel his strengths
are attacking his weaknesses and this is
a self diagnosis and one fun fact about
him is the Prague is the fourth youngest
Grand Master in the history of our game
so unfortunately even the youngest was
some of the youngest grandmasters in
history make blunders everyone right
here this move 94 kind of played in
instinctively thinking alright I'm on
the grind I wanna threaten tactics just
completely missed this tactic on g7 here
but way you did not and that's the
tactic that just happened yeah so
they're coming from a mile away because
then anytime I see a vishwam b2 on the
long diagonal I was saying can I get my
Knight to f5 and just poke at the g7
pawn so unfortunately for Prague he just
missed it and now ideas were night h5 to
f6 come to play yeah night right no Lee
no protects the Bishop on g7 but if I
can remove this night from efore they
don't get the f6 square from my knight
so one of the funny things though is how
all in a black might go if black just
gonna take on h3 and kind of laugh in
the face of danger so certainly way he
is gonna be calculating whether he can
get away with not h5 or whether he just
needs to back this bishop up safely and
okay he kind of does that
yeah the guarding the pod a more prudent
decision in fact I completely forgot the
h3 pose under attack and this is what
happens we have tunnel vision right you
go all in for the attack and you forget
well actually some of my own pieces are
hanging and some picture matrix is the
smart decision just to say I'm a little
pawn your king is very weak I'll clean
to h5 through Paulo with Knight to f5
and try to check meet you and you
started the board d4 Saint good wow I
like that move yeah you have to play and
look this time Stewart Dania under a
minute right now yeah they're both under
a minute and this there's still a lot of
action I would call it blunder potential
on the board right so let's let's see if
we can now get our first glimpse into
how these guys are gonna handle mutual
time pressure with a lot to think about
rookie 5 right yeah he just found a
counter shot stopping Knight f5 which
would I have a meeting it's not in store
and now the Queen has to retreat
somewhere feel queen g4 check out trade
Queens and take on e3 so you actually
I'm not Street weeds here honestly
despite that huge blunder on g7 Prague
has held his own now forcing the Queen
all the way back to d1 there's no way
we're use happy about that just play
quickly play rook d8 I understand so
down upon worse but just play quickly
because right now it's been down to a
bullet battle we have 30 seconds under
36 for both players you cannot spend 10
seconds 15 seconds here and he's going
really low in the clock right now yeah I
don't know what he's thinking about he's
trying to maybe over calculate the
position which
as you said Robert it's just probably a
mistake based on the fact that you don't
have enough time to justify being being
a scientist here you got to be a gamer
right every moment in chess are you
calculating for perfection or are you
understanding the gamesmanship the
practicalness of the moment and and
pushing yourself to be quick so I agree
with you he needs to just play fast yes
whoa he takes he three Queen d7 is gonna
be met by EF two in her MS Oh but he's
losing the exchange the hi Brooke
White's gonna play King g2 and then take
the rook next no he takes up two because
the rooks hanging on design he's got a
tempo got it but okay so some counter
plan in a blitz yeah this should be for
genetics laughs [__] protect that night
get your king some safety when it just
like takes g3 what was probably with the
Oh Richie - I'm sorry oh okay Wow Bishop
takes up four now now okay it was just a
just a fancy way to get to a lost and
game if he did that and indeed he goes
down unfortunately in game one well an
interesting start here though right by
the underdog you know he got out I think
to a you know to a position that you can
be happy with with the black pieces as
you said we're going up against a guy
like Wei Yi you quoted the the game of
maybe the this century right his win
over bruised own Batista but okay I
think if you're if you're just shaking
off that loss and knowing that it really
all fell apart with that single blunder
Bishop takes g7 I'll remind people here
on the analysis board where this one
fell apart it was just just this kind of
single move right here for Prague he was
in good shape but got a little overly
aggressive with 94 and missed the four
key moat right here on f5 and that
that's why this game fell apart so okay
now back to the live position I mean I
think that you can still kind of say
that you feel good about that game won
Robert despite losing yeah I don't feel
great about the time mismanagement I
think that he got a solid position of
the opening but you need to play more
quickly and it's not like way he was
playing that fast either so they kept
about level in the clock it was just
unfortunate for Prague that he blundered
it spawn and so ways position just
became much easier to play now that said
I'm always thinking long term here
what's gonna happen in the bullet
portion right that's a last
well you can really catch up with you're
down three games and go on a quick
winning streak and tilt that's a chance
to get back into the match so I did not
love the situation with the time engine
that first game but I will say Danny is
sometimes having five minutes to start
the game makes you feel like you're in
this comfort zone I have plenty of time
that when you get down into time trouble
you don't really think in terms of
bullets strategy I just need to play
quickly so are you speaking from
experience right now Robert I'm
definitely from you know when I get into
games with three minutes with two second
increment or something like I have all
the time in the world and then when I
get down to 20 seconds I still have time
and that's not the case but right now in
this particular game I look at this
setup by wayy with his g6 move of course
that's to make tonight on g3 look a
little bit silly right at pawn three
squares away from a knight takes away
two of the squares from that night in
this case it had 5 and h5 but here the
weak dark squares in an eventual pawn to
f4 and a quick blast on the kingside
could spell ways do okay well we we know
is not afraid of dynamic situations
let's talk a little bit about who way he
is we already of course helped you get
to know Prague but let's remind you that
wayy is a little bit of a of a different
cat in regards to who all these juniors
aspire to be in the chess kid the
juniors beat Chess Championship you
can't really describe to be any better
than the number one jr. in the world
Robert Wei Yi is the highest rated
player under the age of 21 on the planet
as he said he loves puzzle rush which
was awesome that was of his own interest
I don't know if he I don't know if he
thought we were asking him what his
favorite feature is we were just like
what are you interested in he's like
puzzle brush we're like ok but he loves
tactics he feels like positional chess
is his weakness right very kind of self
reflective therefore a GM who's touched
the over 2750 realm I don't even know
what his yeah ok he's not over right now
I can see the writing in front of me but
they use the fifth youngest GM of all
time so interesting stuff right getting
to know these guys a little bit yeah and
I saw a car not the more in the chat by
the way saying that this was nepo wait
ah check so first a shot to hit card
nothing more being the chat but the
difference is in that game I don't think
niebo committed his pawn to g6 I'm sorry
but nipple was white what's more toxic
toxic g6 at least not this early
and so the night never went to c6
because the minute c6 actually allowed
this 95 captured with the tempo so he's
a bit different but yes it is important
to note how the top players will see how
other top players play and Geffen nor
try to replicate that success well you
you highlighted that one way white tries
to take advantage of this is now with f4
and I think from a positional
perspective kind of interesting to note
that if you give black a few moves
this night will feel like more of a
donkey if black can get away with things
like f5 and bring a knife from d7 to f6
behind the pawn structure then you
really like the the duo of the pawns but
white is gonna try to challenge that
oops that's not a move that was played
why it's gonna try to challenge that
dynamically preventing things like f5 is
he is he just threatening something like
f5 I think here would just be met by a
capture and then Bob's your uncle over
here on the G file so it's an
interesting move the queen of three
fields
anti-soviet chess Robert it puts the
Queen in front of the F pawn instead of
your suggestion I guess to open up more
lines for the pieces your thoughts on
whether Queen of three is a better
approach here to the Kings side than the
move you were first mentioning with f4
yeah I'm actually not certain I really
love this strategy by white and really
stems from d5 so early because I'm
putting your 95 you allowed block to
make this capture and I think in the
long term having the black potential if
I have seven f5 is just extremely strong
that's it quickly obviously stops that
and I'm loving White's time advantage
right now you're up on the onion on the
clock black with the blacks pieces you
haven't developed anything so you're for
white you can play try plate for c4 and
then apply for b4 and try to expand on
the Queen side but I actually have to
admit I'm not a big fan of this early
nike5 I really think that it favors
black especially in the Blitz game where
you're always worried am I gonna allow
this move f5 to happen so if I'm white
I'm considering a is gonna go Bishop f8
and trade those bishops off and then
play a 5 and that way worries me as
think about this from the wife's
perspective no I'm with you III that's
kind of what I was alluding to is that
the positional game
kind of long-term favors black if you
can get this structure and just because
of the control over the center square is
just kind of the basic principles of
chess that everyone can follow that if
white doesn't have some way to
dynamically prevent this or I guess as
you said c4 before I guess could come
quickly oh wow that's how you
dynamically prevent it but is it work is
he just or is this just a big smoke and
mirrors can actually he can take f8 and
if Knight takes you of Knight h6 check
and if King takes the d6 pawn Falls but
actually six check I guess there's no
King to g7 and say if you take with your
queen on f7 you lose your knight and h6
with your 9mf 7io Queen e7 trapping your
knight so it's actually it seems like
Prague made miss evaluated this
situation where looks like Bishop fate
wins something at least a pawn but
actually you're gonna cost you a piece
in the process yeah he may just have to
take on a fate and tuck his tail between
his legs and back up right but something
like that will be immediately met with
f5 and then that positional thing we
talked about is gonna come to fruition
with white having lack of access in the
center this seems like something a
younger player might do against a more
experienced player like get a little bit
excited right play a move like Knight f5
thinking alright here we go
something that I might do right and then
Bishop f8 and it was all just a bunch of
nonsense right yeah yeah I see Prague's
internet connections that one bar that's
not gonna help them at all either but I
didn't like the nike5 so early and I'm
not liking using internet connection and
thus I'm not like his time situation so
seems like he might be disconnected yeah
it looks like he's actually frozen on
camera too unless he's gone
unless he's gone mime mime imitation
mode I don't know sometimes people do
that I hear um yeah actually it looks
like we've got got some connection
stability issues here for Prague
unfortunately we'll see if he can he can
recover but regardless I think there's
still a lesson on the board I think that
back to your point all the way back here
in this position after Knight to d5
Robert or instead of 95 was F for an
option right then maybe the white f4 I
think Bishop c4 was also a reasonable
looking move as well just to make sure
you can capture the piece on the d5
square so I just you know okay mine says
you say oh I don't like playing eat 65
and giving black the huge center but you
know it's really not liking what's
happened here and locate his time
situation he's about to lose out time I
think of me
is he coming back looks like he's back
he's got a stable connection he's on the
on the screen again which makes us happy
right he's got got his camera back on he
seems to have reconnected to the chest
comm server but but he's going to be
facing a big time disadvantage
unfortunately he's also been facing
efore f4 b5f zillion that watts position
place itself so yes this is this is
getting rough but this is this is a good
a good lesson there from there's a
difference in recognizing your opponent
having weaknesses and the the getting
overexcited to take advantage of them
right Robert I mean black clearly had
some potentially tactical landmines
there but Prague got a little bit too
excited with this 905 move regardless of
the connection issues and now he's now
we see that big pawn Center for black
coming to life you just have to like
blacks position absolutely I was
actually watching the game earlier
between Valentina boo Nina and Katarina
Lucknow from the women's candid
tournament and it was a pollen jocks
were very similar work
why hit upon d5 but black of the 4-3 on
the kingside and I don't know if they're
still playing but it was all black in
that game Lucknow and right now it's
it's very easy to please position for
everybody you can go h5 to kick the
night back to h2 and then I've kind of
just trapped there for the future you
can also like Queen to g5 ok Queen h4
close a good but I've seen g3 here just
to break open the palms just go for it
yeah take it well I think the biggest
issue with g3 is black was probably
gonna take h3 and even something like
Knight f6 is eventually met by f3 from
what that's not ideal that's for sure
yeah I don't know that you were wrong
that it was the the right practical
point of view regardless but I think
that I think that he's got his work cut
out for him here I was also thinking
what I would do with having five seconds
on my clock
because you know just just moving and g3
at least allowed me to make a couple
quick moves or so I thought here rookie
three comes and delegate why just toast
rookie three Queen to d1 black can't
even follow with f3 looks like yeah he
does so Bishop takes pawn age three and
then we check throw the check ins yeah a
very nice little instructive game of
tickle there for everyone to take note
of if you can take a piece with tempo
always do it now Queen g3 Queen h4 wins
the bishop on c4 so that's a very nice
little spot there that's a little puzzle
rush right there Robert yeah go way to
eat your Wheaties this morning you know
I'm a charity stream you did a lot of
puzzle Russian I'm feeling ready very
nice little spot keep an eye on all the
hanging pieces that's how you find
tactics like that and and there you go
alright well you know we have two games
in the books not a huge surprise in
terms of how people kind of looked at
this match a two-game leave for the
overall one seed but that second game
was a little bit more of a kind of a
blow I think to Prague then the first
one was right so just having having
really miss played a better position
regardless of what happened with his
connection and now he needs to recover
here he's played better with the black
pieces so far yeah I agree with that I
think a lot of people chalked it up to
oh he got disconnected he lost two
minutes or however much time it was but
I agree with you that he actually was I
think gonna losing the board no matter
you gotta mix it or not and that's not
insult to his chest skill I just think
that the position got away from him and
yes anyway he's favored by that point
and right now we see Prague with a
double fianchetto set up with the black
pieces here and right now but this
situation for white but this knight on
f3 when you rather you're Pandian f4
near night behind it on f3 to get a
little bit of an advanced structure that
gives you more play because if I'm black
I'm saying I just go see five right now
it right now or should I leave the
Pawnee seven so my [__] when g7 so
strong but I don't want white to play d4
so actually I don't know I'm not no
you're totally right what you're
highlighting is this is actually a
bought Vinick English structure for
those of you who speak closed opening
repertoires the knight normally belongs
on e 2 though in those positions
precisely because of what Roberts
talking about it allows f4 to come in
it's a more flexible structure for white
also because the 92 guards the other
night on c3 which sometimes can help
back up a 95 plan so okay
wait he's gonna try to fix this this
mistake of the night being in front of
the F pawn but I think there's still a
ton of flexibility here he plays up for
he might even considered as bringing the
knight back to f3 being very patient in
the position collection is 8 4 as well
just trying to close down the Queen size
a4 yeah I think so the question and a
lot of these positions Robert is how
much do you take your time being
prophylactic in your approach right
preventing your opponent's breakthroughs
versus calculating that you know what I
can allow things and just go all in for
the race g4f v g5 and I try to prove
that I'm gonna be the one who wins in an
all-out kind of race attack I would
always sort of advise my students to be
a little bit more prophylactic in nature
in positions where your opponent has a
very solid King side meaning they have a
fee in keto structure you're not just
gonna sack sack mate right this isn't a
Yugoslav attack so be patient stop your
opponent's counter play and build up the
attack slowly you you dig in that kind
of advice for our viewers here two
things though profil axis is very hard
word to spell and I'm not one of these
scripts and second of all you make a
great point about said prophylaxis
because f5 is now on the board and what
f5 does it gives black the e5 square for
the rest of the game and that's
something that really worries you as
let's say a former close or a reformed
close Sicilian player like myself as I
know that anytime I push this F on f5
look at that key five square and I can
hop in directly the bishop on g7 looks
beautiful with all the dark squares
covered and so where is White's attack
the knight on h4 is misplaced but it was
needed to go to h4 because it was like
on f3 in the first place and this idea
at g5 what's it gon go played before I
wanna just go take your phone with me -
I don't see your attack isn't the check
made me which means I can go snag some
Queen side pawns and just play for an
advantage in that way that's those are
big words coming from as you said a
reformed closed Sicilian player who at
one point played a lot of these attacks
as white but the question will be
generous way to put that isn't it but
you will be whether way
you can prove us wrong with some sort of
mating attack making these pawns into
something but the other question for all
of you regardless of a way he's facing
is our daily question and let's go ahead
and remind everybody that they can get
involved on social media whenever
they're watching any of our events here
on chess comm but today's is what is the
greatest tournament performance of all
time by a junior so Robert this is what
I'm really gonna challenge your chess
knowledge because juniors get invites to
things like the Tata Steel B groups
right or they get invites to often their
local wild cards and otherwise super GM
elite events right and I think that
throughout history sometimes you get
your first glimpse into the stars of
tomorrow by how they do in events like
that right people remember when guys
like Magnus Carlsen Hakkar Nakamura made
their first kind of big like whoa a 13
year old or 14 year old just won this
this event so I'm gonna ask everybody to
get involved use the hashtag speed chess
we'll see what Robert comes up with as
he thinks about this throughout the day
and let us know your answer to the daily
question
and by the way Prague did just go pawn
grabbing he has played better as black I
get the feeling we might see that he's
not gonna go away quietly this looks
like a game that black should get right
now I'm with you I don't buy whites
attack I think ye went a little bit on
tilt with this with this Knight h4
all-in on the F and G pawns okay I would
never
so I always have to compliment Prague
for his play and then I saw this King on
g7 which is just a frightening move for
me to see because that means f6 will be
a check at any moment teeth will become
an option if you want to blast open that
diag you know what to check I don't
really see the benefit of having the
King on g7 well I guess you're stopping
a sacrifice in the g6 quest maybe I
should hold back for a second but I
would put my 95 or brought my knight
from EA to g7 before I ever played a
move like King G so maybe it's a good
move I could be drilling off here but
somebody feels so wrong about having a
king on g7 because more vulnerable to an
attack queen g4 finish for Queen h6 now
it is a check that's you know Adam the
picture here h4 h5 you know that's
another idea that you can play because
you just moved your knight back so I'm
not a big fan of King g7 that I think it
just puts you in a danger or danger than
it's worth and you know what again to
highlight it and we're gonna be talking
about themes of course throughout the
tuners features championship because
these are kids
presented by Cheska they may
sometimes reactionary moves right Robert
if we back up and look at why did he
play King g7 on Bishop before white
immediately kind of you know sort of
bluffed at the idea that I'm gonna take
and go to sac town on g6 and Prague
quickly responds with an instinctive
response to say no thank you right but
the problem is the big picture is that
that King is actually more vulnerable as
Robert saying on the diagonal and I
actually really liked where use move
Knight G to because it actually opened
this path for the Queen that Robert
highlighted to h6 so again I think that
a good lesson is always you know be
careful how you react to your opponent's
threats don't see ghosts right there
sometimes you stand at the top of a
stairwell and it's really dark and you
know you should be careful going into
the basement that doesn't mean there's
ghosts there right it's just like
recognize what the situation is but
don't overreact and put yourself in a
weird situation and in chess Jeremy
Suman talks a lot about that not seeing
ghosts calculating and and making sound
decisions rather than just kind of
reacting to your opponent's threats I
don't know for those of us who like
horror and things that you would like to
see a ghost
yeah Hill House great show that in a
great book I might add that came out
recently so you know I don't mind a
ghost every now and then but I agree
really didn't completely but if you look
outside how much time he spent on King
g7 I believe was two seconds yeah just
total a reactionary move yeah and maybe
that's in part because he feels himself
getting in trouble in this situation
when he doesn't much time left so he'll
I'll save the time now and use it later
in the more complicated situation but
look at the position once attacks isn't
playing itself Queen g4 here
I played queen g4 consume like Queen
over to H 4 H 3 depending on the
situation quiz you throw also threatens
f6 check winning the night on d7 hanging
so I mean look at this Bishop on e4 it's
protecting g2 from any sort of attack
there and aiming of the g6 square anyway
so yeah he agrees yeah I think we're
gonna see 95 is a again a reactionary
move but you're right we're we're now in
a position if we're black where we've
we've really given white the potential
for tempo moves around our King side
with this move King g7 and tempo moves
that come with check powerful threats
are are dangerous and sometimes easier
for blunders to happen especially under
time pressure you know what's really
easy to do though if you're watching
this at chess calm or your homepage
chess calm
the player you're watching it on head
over to twitch.tv slash chess and and
give us a follow so that you can be
alerted in the future when the biggest
events in chess go live and if you're
just tuning in about 4000 of you with us
thank you for watching the jr. speeches
Championship presented by chess kit so
all right Robert how do you deal with
Queen chief or the threat of f6 check
and the night hanging on d7
I mean 95 as you mentioned is definitely
the best move but after many fellows
this 95 said Queen h3 or Queen h4 I
don't know which square is better but
okay I like your h3 just feels a little
more like I'm guarding g2 even if I
don't need to yeah I agree
and now hg 6 and the creation extent ly
threat yeah they just highly oppressing
the g6 on so that means you might have
played rook h8 to meet hg 6 of hg 6 with
tempo but after rookie cheating I would
even consider h6 check yeah Oh Robert
highlights that this is a common team
that happens sometimes
oh here we're gonna see something like
this oh he plays f6 wow so wayy thinks
he has more than just trapping the rook
but given the Prague is already about to
be under 30 seconds and the attack is
raging I'm liking way e again despite
Prague starting out on a good foot here
with the black pieces it's so funny
Danny huh f6 check is obviously an
option but I was so used to like this is
weave h6 and like rook in there that he
actually may have sex didn't even come
to mind but when he played only oh that
was obviously a good move but actually
the reason I don't love it so much is
now it's black something to counteract
right this pawn on f6
it looks very menacing it's taken with a
g7 square I'd love to hot like Queen to
h6 right now but I can't jump over my
pawn never go H sees g6 then after each
takes back the rook on h8 is beautifully
place so if you'd ever take on e7 then
I'll swing my queen to e8 gobble up that
ball queenie 8 right now and gobbled up
on up usually so now this yes some f6
became almost way Yi's reactionary move
assuming that must be the better way to
put the King on his heels and block the
rook but I think you're right Robert I
think f6 was was not the most accurate a
way to keep continue the attack though
take on e7 Queen see a check is the idea
for white bent by 98 and hope that
you're not getting maintenance it sounds
ridiculous hope then you're not getting
made it but right quickly you don't have
time and everything I hope not to get
made it all the time Robert I don't
think it sounds silly yeah
I mean you can't he's ten seconds left
and so Queen see if Queen see 898 rook
takes d6 is that what's gonna happen
oh man that could get real nasty Queen
City 898 rook takes d6 can't take as
takes or can you could you block on f8 I
don't know we're gonna find out but then
you could take on that Fame and take on
c5 and how does that transition ah yeah
yeah that's an exchange where White gets
a ton of pawns he's gonna go for it he's
spying that d6 pawn yeah you're kind of
sort of forcing White's hand away
because once it's 95 moves then we're
kinetics really is under attack so you
have to look out for discoveries like
Knight takes e4 potentially actually it
was really good it's the bishop needful
will also be hanging if you go D takes
you for it but right now you can't play
nice e4 because rook up 7 so it's like
Queen up feat but if he actually stops
the pin Oh Oh giving him the f7 it's a
it's a blunder with no time in the clock
yeah I was gonna say he was living off
the increment didn't have a choice the
d7 nightfalls with it Prague shakes his
head yeah and we we feel your pain
Prager's in regards to making blunders
when I say we it means like the Royal we
like isn't me Froggers that's awesome
the the Queen's guarding h3 in case you
didn't get the memo Prague gets it right
yep and all right well that you know
again if you're just joining us everyone
obviously you see what's on the
scoreboard the 1 seed overall in the
Junior speeches championship doing what
he came to do which which is kind of win
this match he's up three games to nil
but but a couple of these games
especially the two is black have been
really good starts for the young star
from India and he just has kind of lost
his way in the critical moments a couple
times and it's led to some instructive
stuff though I think that we're seeing
we're seeing some mistakes that people
can relate to very quick reactionary
moves right Robert you know not
necessarily calculating the big picture
when you put your pieces on dangerous
squares and and Prague did that with the
king coming to g7 and last game and paid
the price
hey Dan you have a psychological
question for you here yeah if you white
you know your Prague you're done three
nil do you just try to be safe and just
get some kind of half a point or do you
just do your normal thing and say if I
lose again that's just chess and maybe
it's not my start but I
can just resorts and making drawers
because I'm down on that score so I
would I go back to whatever advice I was
given and I think that I kind of
subscribe to the theory that as much as
you don't want to and as much as I maybe
haven't always led with example and this
is I think at this point you have to
stop the bleeding just to get yourself
on the board psychologically because if
you tell yourself no I might as well
keep going all-in now might as well keep
going all-in now that's usually how like
real landslides and tilts happen right
and I think for me it was very difficult
as a kind of an emotional passionate
player when things were going well for
me
they were going really well when they
weren't going well I would kind of start
sliding and I think that one of the last
skills I've really learned is like as I
when I was a good chess player Robert
and you can say if you agree was to kind
of like not let my passion lead the way
be disciplined understand like there's
nothing wrong with the draw you have to
remind yourself how to just play
unbiased solid chess and get yourself on
the board but what would you what advice
would you give if you were coaching
Prague to say you know what forget it
and go for it would you say hey man you
know get yourself on the board take a
breath well you said landslide I got
distracted because that's a beautiful
song by Fleetwood Mac but I'm serious
landslide brought me down sorry go ahead
I mean sing it for me Danny I'm ready to
wear it hey Stevie Nicks is right here I
keep Stevie Nicks right here next to you
in my heart next to the world oh yes for
this particular landslide I agreed that
you know I was always told that you just
you can't Castle queenside and that's
what he's done right zero zero zero
three losses and I voted like you need
to just get half a point get that
feeling of not losing and that can
rejuvenate you and revive your chances
that said if I'm in a speed chess
championship match where there's a
finite amount of time and I know that
I'm kind of against the clock my
Commission hasn't been so stable I feel
you just kind of play at this point you
are the white pieces and so you know
there's no I like a setup he played it
in exchange caro-kann which means that
it's generally speaking a very solid
position look at the the situation there
no pawn breaks for black speak of right
now white is very solid official on g3
is excellent League place if you play me
like Bishop h5
I go Knight up four take two to bishops
and why is that important well generally
speaking in a position like this it kind
of lowers your losing chances and John
say playing to draw
but he's playing for two results trying
to play see approach it means that
there's no tactical fireworks because
honestly speaking he's been on the worst
side of the tactics thus far ooh reg
that's five I think that even this will
be a position Dennis over I would call
it a two result position right away we
see way Yi's connection just died there
but now he's back but I would say that
even if you take here and then try to
route a couple of nights into e 592 to
f3 Knight f4 to d3 I start spying these
outpost squares on e5 and c5 and
prognosis I like Knight f4 also does the
same thing I was saying instead of just
leading with this Knight you leave with
the other night coming to d3 oh and this
is also a strong idea positionally I
feel like Prague is kind of flexing a
little bit here in terms of white
structure you're threatening to take up
six which of course means you're
threatening to defy upon everyone and if
and if black just kind of over over
defends this week pawn that gives white
a bit of a free hand to develop the
knight to the f3 square maybe grab the
e-file so positionally I'm liking widen
again for all 4000 of you with us if
you're just joining us this has this
does feel this doesn't feel like a match
that is gonna see any of the a-word
right the adoption right I feel like
Prague is going to get a game here he's
been close and several of the the
matchups we've already seen here
everyone and I'm like and white again
it's a very instructional moment and he
just started rook to da but what I was
gonna say is that which my pieces do you
want to trade do you want to trade
Bishop for Bishop in which case he would
have won 94 but clearly Prague wanted to
trade the bishop for a knight and I know
for many less experienced players I here
wait a second but isn't two bishops it's
just advantage firstly there's no two
bishops here and so this [__] one f6
what's it going to target look at this
beautiful paunch in for white b2 c3 d4
that restricts the bishop on f6 the
night on b1 can quickly hop into d2 and
as you were mentioning f3 and what's
black gonna do about it
well I can put my knight on c4 but if I
ever trade the remaining Black Knight
white will try to put pressure on the d5
pawn because black does have a light
square bishop to help defend it now one
hand how many light square bishop means
is restricted by your own pawns but on
the other safeguard some squares in an
endgame diff you can
in this position without the Knights
well the D to C for Knights it without
the major pieces then we say ok I have a
dark square bishop but why he has a
knight that can hop from color to color
and that's C of a knight over a bishop
is that it can occupy both diagonals
both colors right and black the dark for
Bishop can only be on the dark squares
no it sounds basic but it's but it's
really critical in terms of how you're
evaluating the future of these positions
way obviously trying to win the staring
contest hoping that white will settle on
a move like takes here which of course
would be bad because it fixes blacks
isolated pawn what White's probably
still better here with with a protected
pass D pawn and a good night but but I
think that Prague is going to try to
play from more than just trading on c4
but no you're absolutely right Robert
this is a really good positional lesson
we'll see if fraud can convert on it
this is our third match of the year
let's remind everybody of the schedule
well we have a a small break in the
action before we see how Prague tries to
convert this we've already seen 2 in the
books there the next matchup will be on
June 3rd between American star Sam
Savion and another rising star from
India anyhow ahran and mark your
calendars there get your iPhone out
cancel that dentist appointment on June
14th the cavity's not hurting you yet
anyway right you don't have to get
dental work until the cavity hurts this
is that this is just known ok so cancel
your dentist appointment on June 14th
and join us and then mark your calendar
for the long schedule which is the
quarterfinals and semifinals where those
dates also potentially subject to change
based on who we end up having there but
most likely those will be the dates so
mark them down and join us
rookie 4 I actually really like this
move though this is this is where ye
starting to get the dynamic counter play
to maybe make up for his positional
weaknesses here Robert well I really
don't like to be 3 and actually I was
going to mention it before but I thought
well I don't want to mention before I
mentioned b3 and so b3 the pup will okay
I don't know what night a3 he's going to
be 5 anyway but I would have put my 96
and I said look at your opponent's c3
that's a new target that I can just try
to pile a pressure on and then what I
mean by that is rook c8 95 Queen c6 some
kind of configuration like that and well
the secret fall is a new target you're
not getting c4 in which would one make
your d4 pawn vulnerable
and two I just had that square covered
pretty well so 84 good move and now
Knight d6 and I don't think that the
inclusion of a4 and Queen B 2 has
actually helped black about 96
immediately leaving the Queen on c2
where was on the C file which means that
a Brooke seat would have pinned to c3
pawn maybe that was a little bit more
precise but I still think that the last
several moves have helped blacks chances
not whites I agree a hundred percent and
even though we were we were sort of
highlighting the positional advantages
of the whoa you saw a lot of moves jump
ahead there oh no no I somehow I jumps
to the the other board
oh that's cuz my my mouse is so right
now I'm fixing my mouse everybody
batteries are out so give us a second
the live position not on the board right
now so hold on this is fun no it is now
yeah all right so let me talk whoa rook
843 what don't be some mousy over there
and don't be so mouthy yeah I like Chi 3
but I'm also worried about g3 because
rook takes h3 the point up clearly is
Knight to f4 for King rook on h3 and
pawn d5 but after black retreat stay
with rook to h6 and why I say white
takes Knight takes d5 can black just go
g5 of an f4 and just crashed ok did not
go for that I really like that idea
instead I don't like this so much does
now Watson playing h4 and if white
placing each for it and then you know 95
and just plays naturally I feel like
blastin have a harder time with this
rook sort of entombed over there on h6
neither sides committed I think both
sides are a little bit reluctant to do
anything too drastic here and I think
that the status quo favors black oh wow
now there's tactics g4 here for I was
gonna say have four played two times
more would have been met by g5 everybody
is he gonna go a night at 5 and go full
Sactown no he goes for a cage for but
now the knight can come to f3 oh no but
then you'll see Brooke take c4 check
right watch out knight of three rook
takes g4 checking out
lack is weight 9003 rubgy for coke
teenage - because he looks trapped there
oh wow that would have been a nice
tactic here Robert Hess Knight f3 rook G
for King h2 and the brook is falling
likely for just a pawn
yeah you're gonna need a mover up to h4
g5 and then I'll take it for a night but
I don't at least give the second bond
and my King feels more safe the truth is
even this approach feels pretty strong
for Prague and again with black being
all in on a move like rook h4 hoping for
essentially now at now a sacrifice of a
whole rook for a perpetual check or
something
so King f1 is you know everything's
gonna happen tonight at five keep it
going your put is 19 seconds left
yeah I think that I think if your if
your way you just keep the attack going
Knight f5 try to made him and make him
find the defense with less than 20
seconds because f3 fails to 1953 and
then the d69 is hanging so that would be
a problem and here if y can't play it
free if you're white because it opens up
III and g3 squares
yep so my thing you have to play f3 you
cannot black to do that does it but here
comes Queen g3 I think so many options
one is Queen h3 check button King my
running e to the DS reason to be careful
about that Queen this position is
getting my blood pumping I'm feeling at
OMGs or snaps coming on but Wei Yi feels
like this is boring
I mean look he's like he's like yeah
whatever I'm down a rock I'm attacking
lol I yeah I don't even know what to say
here because isn't the King run to d3
and c2 so quickly
I think he's gonna lose this one but
again he oh wait Queen of five check
comes in the King's running in d4 24
it's safe completely safe there's no
follow-up for black plague threatening
Queen c5 check
okay so play if you played night if one
Oh Queen c5 you TV three hours like that
King runs out Winkies I think he just
did it
I think Prague just defended the attack
and he's gonna get his first victory any
warning king of the hill 281 at king of
the hill right yeah that should be a
prize in the juniors a special like an
extra little variance prize we know that
fun master Mike loves king of the hill
yeah okay it's three seconds two seconds
there somebody should be it should be a
okay you know you have to block with no
king c1 I thought you had to play Brooke
d3 but this also works for white and the
roof d3 was better because
a c5 number 50 C 383 he had rook takes
c3 he's living off the increment but he
could be blundering oh my gosh i-24
he played Queen e2 with 0.4 seconds and
then 1.3 somebody's gonna lose on time
and I don't know who Oh My Jesus like
they missed a c3 like 5 different times
as making misses and let's highlight
let's highlight what the tactic was
there actually well nevermind we won't
well we'll just go on to the next game
because you know I don't know what else
to say but in those moments Robert the
blood gets extra a publisher gets extra
high at some point we're gonna be
putting a heart monitor on me that's not
a joke it has been a request and we're
gonna see I don't know how to control my
emotions any better I take meds I go to
therapy I'm a human being
ok but Robert that had me on the edge of
my seat that hurt like I was I felt my
heart just beating so quickly there and
I'm shaking honestly part of it is also
because we don't know how good either of
these connections are and again everyone
hates when that's a factor but the truth
is when you're playing in a global match
like this there's the advantages of it
right we get to have the best players in
the world come together and be front and
seat in our living room here some of you
probably watching this in your living
room but you know sometimes you know
players have you know better connections
and others these players join us from
hotels when they're on the road between
other big events and so it gets you
nervous because you just don't know how
they're gonna handle the time scramble
and and there you go there here's me
explaining my emotions which I was told
not to do but yeah anyway ok we're back
to the opening we saw in Game one for
those of you who may just be joining us
if you happen to be watching at chess
comm go ahead and click the player come
over to twitch and hit the follow button
so that you are now alerted the next
time we go live this was a structure we
had in Game one that ultimately led to a
decent position for Prague though he
though he eventually lost
it's interesting to note Danny that way
he refuses to give himself the isolated
pawn because yeah he could have taken
taystee for which I would have preferred
but said he plays well he has I said fun
anyway so I should I an IQ p ok have an
IQ p yeah I think they said there's some
weird opening tricks that instead of
taking on c6 Queen g5 was an option I
feel like I've seen that before but
maybe it's not this position and after
White Knight takes c6 yeah Queen g5 is a
I think there's some inner Missa where
you hit g2 you also hit the undefended
b5 Bishop and the knight is kind of
pinned actually um so that's actually a
really instructive tactic by Robert to
remember and the fact that Prague didn't
find that but also is down on time I
don't know tells me maybe he knows this
position a little bit less than then way
ye but but that doesn't mean I'm really
impressed with White's position yeah I'm
not impressed at all and I think that
yes
Whiteley better for white because of the
development lead but black is just to
move from castling and queen g4 is where
those annoying moves because you can't
shut without losing g7 better before I
play I think Queen f5 continue to offer
Queen trade saying yes I'm giving myself
some double pawns but in a queenless
position my chances of holding really
skyrocket so I think right now way he's
trying to figure out where does my Queen
belong and there's really no great
square for it because black will always
have a Queen move to challenge the White
Queen
yep let's highlight that accidental
instructive nugget from Robert they're
talking about why why the like now Queen
d5 or Queen f5y V I'll go with Queen if
I were to really show what you were
talking about Robert said without the
Queen's on the board it makes blacks
chances of holding despite these
weaknesses much better and part of the
reason for that is that one there's no
open file so that doesn't make it easy
for white these aren't weaknesses that
are easily accessible that's the point
and so without the Queen to kind of
Menace the structure blacks position is
is really perfectly fine and it really
levels the playing field when you have
weaknesses that your opponent can't
attack so yes they're they're unbiased
ly bad pesky but they're also not easy
to attack and so just wanted to
highlight that moment and we see a lot
of Queen moves some sort of breaking
principles here but I like where this is
going for Prague now his Queen has kind
of won the game of shuffle puck here
right and now we
trying to get a queen off the board now
another instructive moment right Robert
would say before it would be fine for
black if the Queen's came off here you
wouldn't really want to trade and open
White's a file and that's why I
highlighted that you know it would be
okay for black the other way but this
would be an example of not wanting to
make a trade and give your opponent easy
access to things like rook a six the
rooks would double on the a file so
sometimes your your assessment based on
what you do has to be on am i making
moves that give my opponent more options
for their pieces or less options for
their pieces and that's a good criteria
whatever you're assessing a possible
trade right Robert yeah I do not like
that move because I was just thinking
about what you were saying and how kappa
blanka would be so fascinated by this
position think about all the intricacies
and nuances of every single Queen move
and every single Queen trade and I
thought 86 exactly why I didn't like
Levi was c4 because now for Queen b3
eight takes b3 the a7 ponens week which
you were highlighting with doubling
Brooks in the eighth file oh he's gonna
do it I agree he shouldn't have a queen
a6 was definitely better so on the note
we were talking about Robert was saying
put the Queen all the way back here and
just get rid of the tickle game and then
go back to your idea of developing this
structure is gonna lead to a to result
position for white for the rest of the
game only white can be happy with access
to targeting these weaknesses with the
rook and maybe black is okay if you play
you know I don't want to play a six but
if I can find a six and somehow run my
King to b7 then perhaps my pawns in the
delight scores are well defended but
there's always gonna be issues of rooks
swinging to the D file as well and it
should be two is annoying but will be
met by f6
so Brett's just a symbolic advantage for
white I think it's more than that
but some you know some of I mean by
symbolic advantage it's an aesthetic one
more than anything but as these isolated
pawns and the Queen side so they can't
protect each other
white c4 pawn is protected from B 3 and
B 3 can be attacked but then you lose a7
which the more valuable pawn and so I'm
looking at this endgame and I totally
agree with you Danny that it's a 2
resulting game for white and there's a 6
that's either a risky move because it
puts the pawn on a light square Bishop
cannot protect it what I like I said I
think that King can run over King b-17
c-17 b7 at the right moment and defend
that pawn as necessary yeah but even if
you do that right you're
groveling for a draw you're hoping that
white doesn't you know get the better of
those two results you mentioned likely
only white can win especially when
you're up almost a minute and a half on
the clock so you know I think there's
been a lot of instructive moments here
in regards to things that are miss
played by our players and that's good
right it lets us all see little little
opportunities for improvement Bishop b2
played I guess to hit g7 stop
development there I can I mean black and
play of six actually I don't like how
this happened is now for good kept d1
check yeah and then there should be five
right yeah yeah you can't you can't run
safely without allowing the Brooke into
the seventh rank oh you know what would
have been a better strategy now that I
see this on the board it's helping me
realize the better strategy for black
where's my f6 King f7 at Bishop e7 and
giving up your a6 pawn because they
would have ripped b8 at the end shooting
the beat yeah you you would you would go
to be eight or d8 even both those things
might be counter play worthy of the a
pawn exactly and I think that it is a
great learning moment for myself and for
everybody is that sometimes the keeping
material equality is a bad decision what
do I mean by right if the activity you
gain from getting your rook up to an
open file or to attacking a pawn is
worth a pawn deficit and actually helps
increase your drawing chances rather
than a passive position like this look
at look at the position what can black
do here f6 Bishop e7 I get that white I
would have played Bishop c3 to a5 and
maybe it's still an option but I would
have starting with bishops he did a 5-2
not even allowed but trade one pair of
rooks because black doesn't have space
and when you don't have space you want
to trade some pieces so if I'm black
here first day through bishops III I
might play 85 myself taking away that
Square and maybe allowing myself to play
pawn to a4 at the right moment to break
open my Brooklyn made but I can also put
a work on d8 and actually rip da right
now looks good for black you have as
much space so you want to trade some
pieces and after rook d8 if we trade on
dating sure if they rook to dese ik's
thinking that you're winning upon well
you in fact do with upon but I have the
move Bishop c7 I believe every six I
trap your work on e6 king daeso
dirty dog
I mean I've been eating my puzzle brush
sweeties you're right yeah you have you
have you well and I I highlighted as you
were talking robber at that long line
about giving up the a6 pawn and getting
counter-plan the be fought which reminds
me of a famous game actually where were
I forget who it was I'm gonna try to
look it up but a very similar idea you
highlighted the need to not over over a
value material versus activity right
giver etske was always big on that right
the active active pieces in the endgame
or were so much more because there's
less pieces so I think that you're right
that black did miss the best defense but
but perhaps perhaps it's it's enough to
hold anyway I look at time pressure as
the biggest weakness right now for black
even though previously it was the pawns
probably now it's the clock absolutely
the clock situation has not been
favoring probably nonde except for the
game before when he won on time but he
also yes up for some ponds and here if
I'm ye I take a moment he's doing that
he's up 50 seconds and actually was
gonna recommend a pawn to e5 and the
reason I was gonna say that for white is
it's just such a confusing move that it
either forces black to play f5 what you
make some of the dark squares weaker or
if you ever take on e5 you know look at
that yes you're saying ee 5 and if you
take you got these horrible weaknesses
and if f5 then maybe even things like
rookie 3 or even stronger trying to
induce weaknesses look everybody g6 you
play tickle again h5 you go back to g3
tickle and eventually whites probably
winning a pawn over here so interesting
to see how you might poke and prod to
create targets there but he didn't go
for it and now Prague is getting a four
he's gonna eliminate one of the
weaknesses he's had for a long time
which is the a file yeah actually this
is now looking better for black to me
because if you look at white spawns
they're more advanced and it sounds like
it's a good thing in endgame but it's
actually makes them easier to attack as
well so how do you get to c6 you can't
really get there I can get to c4 via
eight floors and just played but we
might just see a little repetition here
okay one workday for and in a draw yeah
well this has got to be a huge a huge
success here for Prague he won the last
game if you're just joining us now more
than 6,000 of you with us so if he draws
this one he's kind of on the right track
if you happen to be watching this at the
chest comm homepage
or your homepage at chess calm click the
player and join us over on twitch
because we still have a long match ahead
of us as you can see there there's two
more times which was coming up after the
five minute portion three minute and one
minute chefs so go ahead and join us
over on Twitch click the follow button
above the player so that you can get
alerts whenever we go live in the future
with the biggest events and chess here
and I think Prague has got to be feeling
really good about assuming assuming he
holds this one right here right I mean
he's only about eight seconds we're not
out of the realm of blunter territory
but he might win this because look at
the bish 1.d4 that's gonna be cemented
in there via c5 and then e file c5 right
now immediately v e5 yeah AG has really
let this one go b6 don't trade the music
definitely don't trade this is principle
of two weaknesses you need pieces on the
board in order to have targets and watch
out for black stupid Bishop b2 it should
be two right now oh we missed it there
should be two would have forced probably
a winning rook ending yes because you
always said rook to e7 check winning
that mission notice where he doesn't let
him do it again if that if these bishops
come off and that rook ends up on the
second ring you're gonna see Prague at
his second victory in a row some clan f4
I guess he doesn't do anything really
because he's pushed I think right now
he's looking at the diamond nervous and
play should be to a rook f8 I guess
faith the rooks coming into the f1
square and that King on a4 got himself
in big trouble Robert rook e1 play for
key when you win the pawn he would you
just win the pawn to e3 chat we had a
bishop this is a gue remote shout
everybody get your skewer emotes out
this is really nice fight for Prague
when he was 1.8 second oh and he's gonna
be almost won on time there what just
happened I don't know what just happened
way he is about to lose on time when
somebody's looking I don't know who's
gonna lose on time but I feel like
somebody is alright the King finally
gets a little bit of tickle g3 but II
for check is coming and black is still
in control but how's the rook getting
out there was kind of trapped in with a
king of three rookie still has rook at
five okay so but he blundered his pawn
back wait oh is key g5 king g4 nice he
just missed that looked easy at Prague
rooks it he sit back there because he
knew he messed this up yep he
definitely did and it might be still
gonna be a draw looks like well unless
what Yi gets a little too aggressive
that was a lot happening there that was
it's not over yet I mean with time
scramble situations I feel like anything
could happen
he pre moves taking f5 which was perfect
now the c4 pawn as a target is that key
and you could see by way he's reaction
that he didn't that was that had nothing
to do with connection he just forgot
that he was about to lose on time oh my
no way I mean honestly Prague deserved
more than half a point for that game I
didn't expect the end like that
no let's back up real quick and show you
those last few moments there because in
this position here where he had fought
back from being lost and with 2.1
seconds this wasn't even as low as he
had been but he just let himself loose
on time trying to think about how to
defend the c4 pawn I mean okay several
mistakes were made in that game but I'm
with you Robert that it feels like the
poetic justice suggests that Prague
deserved to win he did outplay way he is
black for the majority of that affair
and we have a match ladies and gentlemen
two games in a row for the young man
from India we absolutely do have a match
and you know you know that even though
probably not three nothing he wasn't
going down without a fight
but now it's three to two and you can't
get in over your head right now if you
are proud because you have the momentum
but that sometimes leaves you to think
that you need to play for a win because
right okay I have wait here on his back
foot he's gonna be in some trouble
okay take on e7 here okay you can take
out any seven next as well and even
trade on d2 with the night if you want
but no you're right I think you have to
be don't get don't get too crazy right
don't let it go to your head
last game of the Year Dan don't hold
anything back you should right this is
not a waterboy situation okay so don't I
don't give a too fond so you might be
three you're still gonna be trading h3
for the epon everyone you don't even
King be one I think cuz there's no word
d8 you'd happily back rank checkmate
your opponent by taking on d8 the basic
puzzle rush is there rook ta you take
choice
but but Wow I'm still a little blown
away about how that last one ended if
you're just joining us thanks for being
here the third match of the year in the
juniors features championship is is not
gonna be a run away at least as far as
we can tell right now the 1 seed up by
one game that's way Yi over the 16 seed
there's his face now he's back on camera
Ramesh Babu pregnant Nanda from India
and this is gonna be a fun one yeah this
actually feels so easy to play right
like Queen III I would even think about
it but Queens are saying if you move you
up from a day sit there it is 887 is
falling and now I can go rook h1 room g1
if I want I can play book to d4 what's
Indy 500 before anyone could take in a 7
there I guess efore would've hung in the
end yeah let's show that tactic there if
Queen a7 rook da rook d1 rook d1 Queenie
4 actually guards the b7 pawn everyone
so that's why he didn't do that
protip actually there's another movie
instead of rook T for it but it looks
super strange rook c1 was a move that I
would have considered as well so I can
play rook h1 and in my other work gene
one version I really want to mate right
you're going out of your way conceiving
an open file because you believe you
will flip the script and eventually get
an attack over here yeah you have open
files right you've given up your agent G
pause which means your Brooks have room
to operate on its side okay he takes d4
look at the pun now there were double
Iceland F pawns and I CH bond now you
have only one pawn island for white
versus 2 for black yeah he's much better
here and you're even threatening at four
right the queen isn't attacking e1
you've got your queen and so I would
just play if Warwick d4 yeah so he can't
do that yet but he plays c3 first
patiently waiting for a pawn structure
to explode on expand on e6 Rd takes e5
which one eise is so tempting east six
yeah he leaned in there you can see the
the palm to the to the head there got to
be calculating east six right now the
potential to blow open this black King
on the back rank yeah you know what this
is you know oh I like that move that's
like that's such a computer move right
it's like just recognizing how valuable
that mature
gonna be and I don't even know if it was
the best but he's just like taking the
pawn and saying like I'm still just
better right I don't I don't need to try
to win with tactics right now
yeah c5 in the first place felt a little
I understand the point you're trying to
break open the Rope because you can't
just how it works tearing down a
protective pawn like that but you need
to prove you a full compensation for
said pawn and right now can i play a
move like f4 because if you play vroop 2
d 3 hours your Queen e2 pinning your
rook to the Queen on c4 so I'm not sure
if black is getting everything that he
thought he would and at any moment east
6 will be tempting but the reason why I
don't like east 6 so much is that even
if Waipa means up upon like as this
outside flank
you know yeah rook pawn as a pass from
the H pawn so yeah he six we can just
trade everything on e6 I think black
actually is the one with the more
winning chance to the endgame like that
yeah agreed and that's a great point to
evaluate activity the ability to to have
the initiative in the endgame not just
whether you're a material so Prague is
taking his time here maybe despite my
compliments of taking C v e6 was the
best move
now you wouldn't do it as Robert said
because you don't want it you don't want
to trade and get the Queen's off the
board and ultimately leave black with a
position with with an x-ray chip on okay
so he plays up for the question is this
Robert if black goes out of his way to
try to regain c5 are we just ignoring it
and playing at five and e6
we might absolutely I mean how are you
gonna regain C father gets to the
question because if you have five then
I'm definitely going a six because
you've cut out H five but I have to like
f5 f5 yeah yeah you know what I might
even do is f6 and make you on the dark
squares but can I go Queen g4 now how
you to protect f5 but even f6 you can't
take it cuz Rick do you want I'm gonna
rip d1 check I missed it
rook do you want check very nice a
double attack right now on the d1 square
and the f5 pawn yeah actually after f6
rip d1 check you still can't take me
because my trade Queen's the h1 but king
c2 and after a king c2 I think I'll have
you take and then play queen up five
check and queen a4 check first actually
okay quit poor check and after b3 over
61 and take out a to a check and
everything sort of falling apart okay so
actually that looks really scary and
frog is leaning in gonna try to
calculate his way out of this one but
never listen to Danny when he says push
your have fun apparently that was the
move we all wish we could have back
right now if you're playing the white
position and you don't else people want
back is I think what he wants is rating
points back because props blintz rating
is so low it's yep leading Leeloo here
on chess Condit weighs like a ton of
points every time he doesn't win uh-oh
he played up six okay rugby one check
this probably lights out is my guess so
Brooke t1 case new queen a four check
yeah III only move because otherwise
rope d1 king c2 Queen a four check B
three you take e1 with tempo and then
Queen Jake say - yep okay let's see what
happens here he played rook to e1 and
king c2 is on the board you might like
route 61 immediately and just by age
four and trying to Queen that bond and
also that's pretty good yeah
wait he is moving a mile a minute there
in his head anyway not a lot of physical
action he actually has been pretty much
in the same yeah pretty stoic all-day
Prague is Prague it's kind of moving
around in his chair a lot okay he's just
ignoring this idea of going for the
Queen side and maybe calculated deeper
than either of us did because he
realizes the H pawn can't be stopped and
the King on c2 is in a really bad spot
because Queen GG will be a check so that
you know I can't age the Queen G - so
maybe it's a stuff dude that looks
really weird by putting the King on b3
just to prevent any check on g2 and hope
that I can get some kind of drawing
chance but this looks pretty bad yeah it
looks too slow I don't know what you do
hear things like Queen h1 going for the
b-pawn or too slow every one Queen h1 h3
you take b7 we trade on sheet2 and black
black gets a queen on g1 way too fast
I think he's busted yeah this is very
bad
east six so if you take with the Queen
on e6 and take on h4 so bright
I'd say with the pawn on e6 blacks King
looks more exposed
but I mean looks gonna be deceiving it's
not really anything or why doesn't but
actual check it where's the beef wrist
so take on g7 probably probably have to
but again h3 just laugh in the face of
danger Simba there you go
you can't even play Queen e5 because you
Queen f5 check the ponies oh he blunders
it the Queen's are coming off and blacks
you're a real wizard Harry on the h-file
it's over progress Ines well that that's
a disappointing one right if you're if
you're the the underdog here because you
had won two in a row and that was not
that was not a game that should have
ended that way right if you're if you're
just tuning into this one let's back up
on the analysis board and show you that
you know earlier if we go as far back as
the middle game in the way this one
transitioned Robin and I were
calculating this position as one that I
mean really only white could probably
win with just a better Center better
pawn structure felt felt good and maybe
he missed his chance for East six here
or maybe he even missed his chance on
what Robert talked about to keep the
rooks on the board and then try to go
for an attack so either way that was not
the he hasn't he hasn't really done much
better than that out of the first stage
of the game in this match everyone so it
the fact that he wasn't able to score
even a half point there that's a that's
a that's a rebound victory there for the
top seed yep and I speeding up top seeds
I see her car not who more in the chat
saying did way he gets sauce for 60
points on those two losses
he's also noting that well I think when
they when they played the the rapid in
India last November right there were
similar situations where some of these
young stars were so underrated in terms
of feed of rapid and blitz that it was
unfair to guys like hey Cara Nakamura
who were there they were you know right
here this is this is definitely a rating
point battle the regardless of the score
is probably gonna be won by Prague today
yeah and I also think that if you look
at Prague feed a know rapid rating
you'll be very surprised by the numbers
you see it doesn't start with the two
let's put it that way yeah and here with
the white pieces we see that way he has
an isolated pond he decided to accept it
that was one of the best twist endings
ever it doesn't start with a two
because it either starts with a 1 2 or 3
and neither one of those is appropriate
right so that's great stuff shoutout to
all 7800 of you with us if you're
watching this at chest calm right now
meaning you were visiting visiting for
some news or you were tuning in to your
home page and you're now watching us
there go ahead and click the player join
us at which and give us a follow the
purple button right above the player so
that you can be alerted the next time we
go live so thank you to all of you that
are with us and welcome to the juniors
features championship still plenty of
more action ahead today absolutely only
six games in and we have 120 minutes
left in the the five-minute portion yeah
five-minute portion and but didn't have
a question for you as we start gearing
towards the end of this or some stuff a
couple games left how do you see the
players chances as the time gets shorter
I honestly liked how Prague has handled
himself I know that I know that he's I
mean he's down two games in the score
book I'm trying to remember how many of
them were time scrambles but I have not
seen a clear edge either way maybe
you've you know drawn and discerned
something different at this point but to
me I think the Prague has shown that
he's gonna be able to stay on the board
and the in the faster portions and the
time scrambles yeah I think he you know
as long as this connection holds up
he'll be in DC I also will say that way
he has found some very important
critical moves like in that last game
the c5 break was may objectively been
totally good for white but I think it
actually unnerved Prague because the
Blues looks so beautiful he had this
wonderful pawn island from a two day you
know yeah it's the F pawn and then he
plays with c5 and then he put h5 which i
think is an underrated really strong
move and they won f5 came he found queen
g4 and all the you know the rest was
history but I think wait he hasn't
played excellent chess
probably the black pieces has been very
impressed right now he's totally fine
where six was in the game in fact I
don't think he's really been worse is
black in a single game one of the games
he should have won during that get away
from him was that kind of bogus attack
white went for that way he has not tried
to repeat oh no way we should note is
actually on pace to win the five plus
one portion with the score that was
predicted I believe and you know so
that's interesting
regards to how accurate how accurate we
can get is the simulations we try to run
through and right now it looks like Wei
Yi is is on pace to win to win the the
five unfortunate kind of kind of like we
thought he would but we'll see if we can
get some surprises yeah she's playing as
an isolated pawn so you couldn't Knight
to c4 I probably started with rook to c8
and the reason why is this is a very
thematic move pawn to d5 for white
because I thought I played pot there it
is
he takes d5 Knight takes d5 Queen 65 I
take on c4 which is totally equal so but
you know it's a success from Prague
right if we just trade everything off
the board and make a draw
I drew a very strong play with the black
pieces that's it I actually preferred
blacks position especially blitz facing
and isolated between pot because let's
talk about that here because in this
situation as Roberts saying this
weakness on d4 is as long as the
structure would remain this way probably
a position that only black and win
that's a two result position for the
underdog right so the moment you allow
white to simplify that pawn off the
board with the tactic which is very
common in these structures you can't
ever
you can't ever turn your back on ideas
like a d5 pawn push you know now you're
gonna be in a position where it probably
should be a draw but the truth is I mean
with with a minute and a half up on the
clock probably white is the only one who
has a tiny edge or tiny pool getting
quicker access to the open files yeah
especially one of the things you're
giving great instruction from lessons
learned by Alex from Olinsky Mike coach
from Iran share always told me there are
certain positions where you calculate
pawn pushes one is if your pawn can go
to the 6th rank then you always consider
it even if it's not the right moment you
should keep in the back of your mind in
other words when you entice a queen pawn
you should always consider it can my
opponent or can i push that iqp I need
to trade it off or gain activity around
it so that's why d5 come so quickly to
me it's one things I always keep in the
back of my mind right here wait so he's
giving a b2 to play Bishop to g4 I guess
and try to hit g7 what am i just all
right we're taking a bit soon there may
have even been rook B whoa I mean there
may have been a number of things so
Prague says I'm not gonna bite I'm not
gonna go for this poison pawn
listen though they meet him wrong maybe
maybe you're right maybe he should have
right frog kind of trusted his opponent
I guess decided not to take it yeah I
definitely was let's look at it if Queen
chicks be - so I was thinking Brooke b1
is an idea you were thinking maybe we
had ideas of a full sack and go for an
attack we'll have to room p1 you can
Bishop before I guess knobs rusting
Brooke b1 i would have either played b5
or because you've been 25 I have Queen
f7 but then okay you're right black
would be better with the two versus one
and that end game yeah Brooke a to d8
incentive b5 also an option making use
of whites poor back rank yeah also a
good point
okay interesting so perhaps perhaps
Prague let way you get away with one
there yeah I know I just like whites
position slightly better no risk
whatsoever and and why do I say that
white is slightly better I look at the
quality of the pieces the Queen on c4
takes away the c8 square in and as Ricky
said emphasizes hates this pawn f7 and
the most important thing in chess it
forces King safety-wise King is very
safe at some point I'll create Luft
through my King so I can get out and I
can start with Queen c2 here I was gonna
say 25 threatens rook to f7 oh look at
you you're getting frisky I was
highlighting on the board I mean I'm not
sure it's even the best tactic Queen d5
might be met by Brooke d8 and then it
kind of is just a fancy trade you guys
for it he likes what you're suggesting I
think Prague should just play okay he
finds this as well so perhaps Queen d5
was really nothing but an exchange on
the board because I mean okay White has
to be really careful you can't be all in
on trying to hold the seventh rank moves
like rook C to c7 fail - Queen e1 and
again Bob's your uncle
okay so I think Prague has defended this
position maybe he should have gone with
Queen e2 if he's wayy like you suggested
yeah now it actually seems much more
pleasant for Prague I was just
anticipating a situation where black is
very stuck and why could you'll create
love or go aggressive in g4 I see a car
yeah in the chat talking about it was
I've been just noticing her car was
comment to play G for now and you say
you're forgetting about the fact that I
want to get back rain now I can play
rook to c7 if I play g4 that'd be a
really instructive and he goes for well
look at that at karo Colin the shot and
I this reminds me of a game a win by
Botvinnik and in a game where again
showing the centralized pieces that just
dominate compared to every one of the
black counterparts allow you a position
where you can play a move that normally
not a move you can just you know do open
up your own King and play g5 but when
you dominate all the access points on
the board you can get away with these
kinds of things can I just say how much
I love it when you reference the
champions of the past you use like
through it about the knick references
just casual conversation on a Saturday
brunch you know what that's that's
that's that's what you bring out of me
here oh it's a two-way he brings out the
the pawn grabber in Prague Nanda
oh but g5 is a Queen e2 with Queen g4
check in 87 okay doesn't route 67 wait
should be to Queen d2 here isn't that
Bishop traps Queen t2 Queen b3 rook b1
and white wins apiece yeah and if 22
Queen 8/3 ship c5 because I take C 1
rook seats you first
aha so Queen G 2 Queen a3 rooks e2 with
tempo after the bishop moves there's a
skewer a double attack here on c5
they're both both did whoa
he doesn't go with Queen t2 and now
black should be fine actually totally
fine hearing the bishop covers that long
diagonal
well not the longest diagonal but the
one that with the Brooklyn f8 and now
you can just probably looks fast look
how fast Prague is playing yeah he's
just move on now so what do you do here
queen bees huh interesting feed a master
chess eclis inclined pointing out that
there were moves Queen a there was the
move Queen a1 check after rook c2 Robert
the inner missive which would save black
in that line Queen d2 Queen III rip c2
not sure I totally believe it but I I
will table it and think about it yes
anyway well either way right now Prague
holding his own the most impressive
thing is regardless of the tactics
they're calculating it with no time
on the clock and Prague is finding his
best moves with the least amount of time
apparently right now you know wait
what's gonna do now no he's got a few
seconds he played it smooth Akane of
mine bull in mind I was just like right
we have three looks menacing even though
it doesn't right it's a bullet to bullet
move now you gotta come up with
something coin a five okay I like this
hey rook c8 maybe Queen does he have he
wanted to take b3 he's doing it he's
just going all in on the pawns this is
gonna be crazy but he seemed like it
made it with no time on the clock though
each six mission be - you have six
Bishop b2 is huge guarding g7 via the
back door way e only 12 seconds he's got
to come over this window wow he just
played that move with 0.7 he's got a
trade on e6 we're happy
oh he had broke up 7 a bishop f8 he
didn't see that do now but he still has
it there was no reason to give up the e
pawn though you ever convey a doubt this
now g6 is coming you might just be stuck
at 4-4 she says she's six and it's it's
it's a cramp
wait what's gone now I have a cramp I'm
getting so excited here
rook takes it for could have taken mine
for that probably draws this doesn't
look good this doesn't look good note
you can't ever leave the F file everyone
cuz Bishop d6 and it's gonna be mate
there are no idea what's gonna happen
here Brooke can come to e3 this has to
be good for white now and Prague Prague
missed his chances freaks out oh man
that was that was a hectic game let's
back up a little bit and see what some
of the critical moments were there that
we weren't able to do when it was
happening I think one of the first
points was that in this position after
the Queen's came off the board Prague
did not have to give up the e pawn which
turned out to be huge he could have
played the move rook F 7 and if Czech
Bishop f8 right away which just a note
things like rook a a now you could have
gone with the move work out five and
there is no F for two guard g5 so that's
just that's just
one note he gives up one pawn and then
gets the same idea but now white is
defending everything I think from a
practical point of view given that black
was living off the increment and already
really under the gun he might have
already been close to lost but as Robert
said rook takes up four probably enough
to draw you play b4 give up the a pawn
and the bishop is really well placed but
but that still would have been really
hard to hold to be honest because the
King is in the wrong color corner with
things like king of five king g6 and
rook e8 coming Robert so anyway I would
have put my key on each seven and then
just like I can just sit there forever
right okay so this this would have been
would have been a another big game there
for Prague instead it looks like way Yi
has has rebounded after losing two in a
row as Robert would say he did not
castles long there was no Oh - OH - OH
Wei Yi bounces back wins the next two
and currently owns a three game lead
just as he did about a half an hour ago
what do you think about this opening
Danny I saw closed Sicilian ask well why
should we ask you what you think it was
pretty good for white considering the
closest ileum
yeah well Plus this is not a very
traditional closest iliyan this is not a
Grand Prix attack this is a very that
move Knight to c4
yeah yet Bishop c4 was not good and way
you finds it right away amazing to see
grandmasters so strong still making
mistakes like that
shout out to Niehaus are in the
countryman of prog nanda just popped up
in the twitch chat Niihau what's up
buddy we know that you'll be coming up
very soon in fact I believe our next
juniors feat Chess Championship match
brought to you by chess kit is Sam seve
on vs. Niehaus aren't on June 3rd so
that's uh that's a fun fact actually and
mark your calendars that's a phenomenal
matchup yeah that's gonna be a great one
and good luck to knee Hal as well as Sam
coming up there and shout out to all
8,000 of you with us right now if you
happen to be watching this on chest comm
click through to twitch give it a follow
not to say you can't chat at chest comm
TV give a big nod to our moderator their
chest wind holding it down
we see title players n m1g for Jessica
Lee inclined hanging out in the chest
comm TV chat as well so evergreen
warrior diamond member has been obsessed
with the idea that prog nonde is playing
from Vichy and Dawn's house I don't know
if he has intel we don't I don't think
that's true
but you know we all kill ourselves
stories so maybe it it's I don't know
how did that get started I don't know
it's just ever green waters been saying
it's as the beginning of the show so
people just you know starting a rumor
mill yep and of course our mods over at
the twitch chat as well
I see wind is helping there as well we
saw chess be earlier Hikaru's been with
us been a fun day all around thank you
for being here alright three game lead
but a pretty good Bishop thank you for
being here that Bishop feels the same
way about this job thanks for inviting
me the bishop says yeah and now the e5
pawn feels like a clear to our 22
already threatens to win the pond and if
I am prog I mean I just sit on the
position there's black can't get any
activity and here ninety to rewrite that
that Pony to e4 this looks so good I
love this position you look so good on
this mug I didn't even see what you were
doing over there the Armenian go mug yep
people would love to have that mug but
guess what it's one-of-a-kind and it
only exists in this office right here
yeah that's true actually I did give you
my only version of them that's right
players who go up by three games usually
go on to win SCC matches I'm just gonna
say that of course you can read the stat
below there shout-out to the chest comm
team who's bringing us info and Intel
like that all day shout-out to the
gifted sub there to Niehaus orrin we
appreciate that and all the love and
support we've been getting from all of
you everybody
k of you so thank you all for being here
and right now we've got well I love
White's position yeah I like the night
coming to e4 you can also play see five
and try to bring the knight in to c4 and
d6 maybe that's even stronger yeah you
can also it's funny
plays Bishop c6 I wouldn't recommend it
right away but you can even play me was
like b5 allowing black to capture on d5
you take with the C pawn to give you
tonight that beautiful see Foursquare oh
that's an interesting idea showing that
on the board here this would be an
interesting way to transition a good
night versus a kind of dubious Bishop
and domination of the light square so
that doesn't happen
probably cuz way you played Bishop a5
but look at Prague just for spawning
with g4 says get out of my house
there goes noisy you for but now [__]
is G 5 goes into F 4 it's why you don't
push this Jeep on too quickly
because you do not want to allow that
Bishop to sit on that for that said
maybe I can just ignore it and play
moves like rook tip e - rope - yeah it's
really irritating let that Bishop come
in to f4 what if I take on e6 my knight
c3 to d5 that looks pretty reasonable
there's Bishop d2 though little fork by
Heiser Queen yeah okay so takes takes
Knight c3 Bishop T 295 okay that's an
interesting way to go about it you know
then d5 square is a beautiful how post
and you know I just wrote it's actually
a perfect square for the knight to guard
f4 as well I like that idea Robert we'll
see if Prague finds it and this to me
I'm not really seeing much better but
maybe - okay he's just sitting see a
pretty good move Bishop f4 will be bet
maybe with similar intentions to take e6
and Knight c3 or yeah actually it's even
more powerful now because Wendy hits
your Bishop on that for ya it was clever
I was wondering if there's some ideas of
d4 at some point to undermine the bishop
of course not right away cuz the Queen
also protects it but maybe the bishop on
f4 is not as solid as it first looks due
to these tactics with the knight coming
to c3 and d5 yeah yeah I like this plan
Bishop e6 and 1093 looks good he goes
for it looks like he does nice Wow
we just had a big gifted sub there from
but there's seven spiders I love that
actually got bit by a spider last night
which just weird coincidence but thank
you for the for the
gift bomb there appreciate it did you go
in the hostel you alright I it's it's
just like a little bite on the ankle you
know when you start itching your ankle
you wake up girl what's going on right
and then you realize oh I got a little
spider bite yeah I get fights all the
time in New York City you know it's very
yeah it's a it's a rough it's a rough
place to get spider-man than a little
spider there's a friendly neighborhood
spider-man protect you against spider
bites or is that like against his code
right he can't fight his own kind that's
a great question
thoughts I do love this 995
and that's probably the best piece we've
seen all day very likely this is the
last game before the 3-1 a portion
begins unless we see a blunder in the
next few seconds so if you're with us
right now don't go anywhere if you're
watching this at chest comm give us a
follow on Twitch sorry that oh no it was
not for people going anywhere that was a
g5 because when I see a position like
this is 95 as I was mentioning is the
best piece all day and I look at the
light squares the [__] will not force
not do anything at all yeah can I just
work around it without using h3 Queenie
fool this is a that's a really
instructive point Robert just to
highlight like if we just took the
Queens off the board right now everyone
if you were able to do that this bishop
would become what we call an empty bad
bishop sometimes bad bishops you think
are blocked by palm structures other bad
bishops are empty meaning like the
bishop has no good targets and y can
play things like h5 pawn on d5 if the
Queen's were off the board the king
would just get surgical up in the light
squares and and white goes on to a very
easy win so I in fact that's kind of why
way he takes he just wants the position
to blow up and get messy because he has
a much better chance there then trying
to play with a good night versus a bad
bishop on the dark squares can I just
say that that would move Age 4 maybe I'm
getting old but it's a move that I
really was not thinking about and I also
think it's one of it's sort of an
impatient move and I don't say immature
in like an insulting way but its job is
an amazing player but H for felt
impatient to me
yeah unnecessary to give the dynamic
tactics that are gonna happen now after
taking an hour g6 for example right now
your King is actually in harm's way
six you go rook takes each for about f5
am I not just like attacking you really
quickly and now the p5 plan both sides
of the board I do love your move b5
preventing white from dominating the
light squares for sure yeah this is I
Division one g5 is actually perfectly
placed protecting up on each floor
that's down extra pawn you can try to go
d4 in an f4 as black but d4 might run
into some d5 stuff anyway and actually
it's much stronger yeah you've really
got to be careful about undermining your
own night here plays b5 to kind of
prevent these ideas but here comes e4 as
an option I like it efore looks good oh
but he 44 I can't sink back you can't
take it right away but even if you can't
it's still becoming quite the mess and I
agree that looks really good Danny Ford
evil queen c8 oh yeah me and attacking
c4 so he does c4 e for the position is
becoming totally wild which is okay he
plays queen c8 which threatens this idea
of e4 so I think 24 first yeah now white
can play Queen e4 though or f3 f3 looks
risky I like Queen you for rook g6 I'd
play I mean there it is yeah Geoffrey f5
threats f5 is gonna get all up in your
business
oh we're now 93 I don't like Bishop d8
at all
oh he had 93 didn't see that that would
have been really strong agreed with you
yeah oh and way Yi says I'm not gonna
let you have it a second time brings the
bishop back to g5 to stop it and here we
get into bullet territory 20 seconds
from white is probably still unbiased
Lee may be in control with the good
night but this has become much much
shaky er than you wanted if you were
looking at this position 15 moves ago
yeah 85 are just pushing it yeah
this says this has gotten away from
Prague is you know Queen D
foreign-trained Queens he's taking a lot
of time here which makes you think by 24
okay please 85 after a huge thing rook
rook b7 Queen Audrey this is the wrong
way
think the brook to be too though yeah he
might have made it he probably will get
beat it TG 1 zucchini 1 KJ 1 bring the
king over you still have Queen f5 though
what's going on here he just goes for
now e5 hangs with check
oh I don't even see that bomb look at
you why didn't he go for efore stopping
the Queen protecting d3 and now the
Queen what's happening here I don't know
this looks good for white teenage goes
to H - there's no checks both sides way
down on time white should get this one
but we'll see a frog can hold his own in
the scramble afterwards the track f7 is
possible though yeah just take it take
again rook rook comes in - 8 - b7 is
there mate or is it perpetual wait Queen
of 1 GF what do you didn't see that
nice and it's over
we never 6 meet him he's got it anyway
Queen f6 when it comes into seventh rank
Wow
and with that we actually have well we
have our first time control at a close
that was that was a crazy and an
exciting finish they're bringing the
five one portion to a close one game off
of the smarter chess prediction which
had Wiggy winning this portion by a
score of 6 to 3 so Prague saying take
that smarter chess predictions I'm not
down 3 games only 2 none of you are down
because you're here with us at the
junior speed chess championship brought
to you by Cheska keep your spirits up
we're gonna take our first break of the
day when we return the 3-1 portion gets
underway and we'll be right back
[Music]
chess kid is fun
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent approve way for your
child to play chess online chess kid is
educational to kids it feels just like
playing the chess is a great way to
learn patience strategy and critical
thinking chess kid features a
comprehensive training program that
guides kids to level up on their way to
mastery
this curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50,000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids chess
kid is easy whether you're a parent
helping your child a coach managing
dozens of kids or a school of hundreds
chess kid helps you organize your
students and monitor their progress each
child receives a weekly report card that
shows how many lessons puzzles and games
were completed you can also organize
kids into clubs and send the messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic checks for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
and we are back now with the juniors
feat Chess Championship presented by
chess kit calm we're heading into the
three one portion Robert and the truth
is this matches is any one's for the
taking right now I think that obviously
a two-game lead how are you favoring the
top seed as you should but I think if
you were evaluating who's been winning
the time scramble battles so far which
is maybe suggestive of the storyline you
see when when we have less time
throughout the match I think Prague has
not only held his own but maybe gotten
the better of those moments
oh he absolutely has we've seen wayy
lose on time in two separate games which
makes me nervous about the bullet
portion for the Chinese superstar and
problem Ananda has got himself in
trouble in some games I think that way
he has outplayed him at some critical
moments but as the clock keeps twiddling
down I really think that Prem has great
chances because of his mouth speed as
he's shown in several games absolutely
and I think that you know you can't
underestimate that this is speed chess
right and those critical moments
regardless of the X's and O's on the
board are probably gonna have have
something to say for it their way Yi
showed a smile kind of a rare smile a
very very serious guy we don't see that
very often so obviously kind of saying
hey whoever's in the room with him we've
seen mom write shout out to Prague's mom
who's been kind of just just lurking
there support her son walking around the
background maybe we'll get an emo for
bronze mom at some point but I think
we're about to get underway here the 3-1
portion is the second segment of the
speech Chess Championship the juniors
features championship going right now I
saw some questions in the chat about who
won yesterday's match Harika Johnny
volley country country fellow-countryman
there of prog nan Donna in India won
yesterday over Marissa bug so that's the
women's speech Chess Championship which
is also running right now so if somehow
some way you're just tuning into chess
for the first time on Twitch hit the
follow button if you're watching this at
chess comm make sure you come over to
twitch and hit the follow button don't
just sit there and chill there give us a
follow so that you can get alerted for
future shows so alright I think we're
ready to begin at least I'm ready Robert
I mean Wei Yi seems ready I'm a little
triggered you're talking about X's and I
was like oh no we can't have that
conversation
every time you say Exynos i got extras
who live in Texas I don't think we wait
are we coating el king or Garth Brooks
who we who according I'm just making
things up on the fly you said all right
good stuff good stuff
whatever we're gonna do is gonna be
Garth Brooks well the games will
probably get underway here in just a
moment and right now what we've got is
another just quick shout out to
everybody that's with us regardless of
where you're tuning in from and and here
we go
three-minute is underway I'm kicking
wait your moves
people keep talking about my missing
beard what do you think Jenny I want
your honest opinion oh I think you look
great either way I mean right now you do
you look you look just like this is the
Robert has I've known my whole life that
beard you know rabbi rabbi Robert was it
was a good friend of mine as well for
that time but you know I don't know if
it was I don't know if it was totally
you okay that's fair I appreciate all
right well the the match continues here
wheyhey taking a page out of Prague's
book we've seen not exactly this move
order now but we saw this opening in
structure played by pregnant andhe at
one point in this match in the v one
portion slightly different of opening
move order now though and and okay so in
this structure what we've got here
everyone is a very solid pawn chain for
white but black has a minority attack
idea at some point b v b4 white wants to
kind of control the breaks in the center
as well try to get a good grip over e v
i don't know i mean i think this is a
somewhat approach for either player at
this point did it wasn't probably white
in that exchange care of congee that's
what I was saying is he was taking a
page out of Prague's book yeah it was it
was it was this you were saying it and I
was listening and I was like wait a
second this looks so familiar but it
definitely was like oh yeah and no it
was the it was the same structure
opposite colors and now it now it's
slightly different move order and I were
telling each other because I'm saying I
don't care brother was a pawn in the
center that gives me the lights from
there it is
what's my least favorite opening the
French the
and so that Bishop on b7 looked like one
of those hideous French bishops behind
it and now it looks like a beautiful
piece so it's a great example great
illustration of how quantity is less
important than quality in certain
situations here you have down upon it's
not that big of a deal when you have
this beautiful unopposed bishop on the
long open light square diagonal I felt
like I was being put on one of those
game shows where we're like we're like a
married couple you're like what's what
is Roberts Lee's favorite opening and I
have to get it right that's the test you
did you always pass alright well we'll
see if if we can hold onto the pawn
despite the compensation but no I mean
from a practical point of view I also
love blacks potential so how do you do
it Robert do you if you move the knight
from c6 to e7 and then do a square like
f5 and g6 and just kind of slow play the
pressure do you look for something more
aggressive in terms of a discovery with
the bishop poking at the brook on e4
what are your thoughts I think I would
refrain from rushing because let's say
you say Queen Deidre looks fine and well
now there's some threats of wreckage for
that you actually have to be nervous
about
I would probably play Knight d7 now that
way everyone XG 6 or the f5 and not only
do I stop the check my own age 7 I
actually attack the rook in the process
so 1997 and g6 looks quite good from D I
go opening up the bishop give you a
knight the f4 square to hop into so that
was good but what it's going to say
before Queen d2 is played is I don't
think black needs to rush with a knight
move because I didn't see a way for
white to really take advantage of the
situation I thought i'ma look to see it
would have been possible if not for
Queen d3 because forget Roe was indeed a
very legitimate threat yeah now now I
would you know definitely be frowned
upon I think because we're cage format
by 96 and you have no real follow-up in
a moment here we're gonna invite
everybody once again to get involved
with our daily question if you missed it
earlier we asked what was one of the
best tournaments in your mind in history
for any junior right we talked about
those those tournaments usually being a
sign of future champions of tomorrow and
so we asked people to get involved on
social media use the hashtag speech yes
and guess who's getting involved one of
the the biggest fan
of tweeting about chess in the world
onigiri super grandmaster of course
rooting for his fellow Dutchman Yoda and
von furries winning the Dutch
championship at the age of 17
hashtag speech yes he's trolling of
course he's trolling but that's what he
does better than maybe anybody I mean
I'll just say it right he's pretty good
at it
and I was chatting with him yesterday
about whether he wanted to maybe join us
at some point as a guest so anis now
then we know you're watching you've
revealed yourself you know maybe we'll
have him on as a guest at some point
when you're deployed says match later on
but who knows there that we got a lot of
a lot of busy tournaments and each is
playing in the grand Chester and quite
busy but we've also had some other
responses to our daily question and
we'll show those here in just a moment
but get involved if you want to use the
hashtag speed chess and have some fun on
social media yep and I see you know a
note senior elite grandmasters I saw
Hikaru Janek are negara Nakamura and the
Twitter chat and was saying white is
just a pawn in black is worse I don't
know at what moment he said that but I
honestly don't fully agree that black
was ever that much worse and I you know
of course he's a very strong player
stronger than I am
so I know I'm picking up the gauntlet to
disagree with him right now but I think
ultimate practice which is a noble cause
well it's hard to disagree with the car
you're right it is
but right now especially I think blacks
position is quite decent f5 is a move
that I can play because makes east sixes
member of de8 pinning and winning the
night but let's no let's analyze for
everyone real quick and know why Bishop
takes g2 wouldn't work that here or
something like f3 actually disconnects
the communication there between the
Queen and the bishop I believe that
would have been the response
there's also crazy ideas like Knight
takes c6 in some positions where d6
falls after a check but so Bishop takes
g2 is not the move f5 quickly met by
Queen d3 600 rook f6 to g6 ok I misheard
you
yeah h6 would have been met by Knight
takes c6 so the rook comes to f6 guards
east six threatens rook g6 and yeah I
mean I hear you and I think from a
practical point of view you and I maybe
sometimes we do get a little excited
about compensation because we've
commentate on so much speech yes but I
think I also would tend to prefer black
which makes us both in the in the wrong
seat I guess in terms of how a car
reviewed this position but right now
it's looking very very dangerous and and
so even if white was better earlier it
feels like something went wrong for Wei
Yi because no it's terrible I mean aged
64 just I don't like to move aged six I
would stop see four I think he actually
went wrong there okay
let's analyze that real quick and see
instead of age six maybe I'm saying
Queen Caesar c8 our Queen c7 one of
those moves probably okay right now it's
still good for black do you just pin the
d4 pawn six seconds for white for three
Oh take that pawn okay yeah well we've
worked in the time scramble now wayy the
went down on the clock and you know
we're getting closer to these big
moments that we know we're gonna to find
the match who's gonna handle themselves
better when the gloves come off scramble
time looks like
Froggy's and take this was okay maybe
rook takes was better though lamb for s4
and keep it stuck oh that's like a thorn
in your shoe or spider bite which I'm
suffering from right now triple isolated
pawns have never been so pretty the ones
that more than a mother can love finally
isolated pawns have their say king f7 or
wherever Kevin Brooke see now you got a
we worry about taking though rook see -
they buggers it no he's gonna go to
China
Rick have to check King g1 in the take a
- okay still in control
yeah 85 84 83 is wins love they just
resigned because let's let's let's talk
about why because if the rook just comes
to d1 and white is completely stuck on
the back rank this a pawn just marches
up the board and literally marches up
the board you play rook b2 a2 and rook
b1 and it's lights out yeah that's
really nice also just crazy everybody
John Ursula shoutout for rating us right
there John Herschel sent the raid yeah
say what what's up boy you know I don't
know what he's up to but you know
raining look John we let you on but it's
five it for Danny
so Prague is the white pieces yeah way
ease
going for the Nakamura heaven Potamus
right now right 97 86 each he's gonna
he's gonna go a 6b 6b should be 797 the
Hikaru versus komodo lives yeah
or B six right away but okay I mean this
is a match and if you you know if you if
you thought this was gonna be a runaway
right right now the one seed is not not
flexing you know totally just yet
against uh against the sixteenth seed
and this choice by way II look at his
time situation right now he's up
eighteen seconds he's playing just
quickly and I think that's a good
decision and it's also an opening you
tend to see higher rated players play
against low rated players obviously
Prague Nevada is a very strong
Grandmaster and he's not gonna be scared
of this opening but you do tend to see
this is just like a waiting opening
right
you haven't commit to anything as but
now you have on the kingside but why
can't take advantage of it you're
pulling g5 pawn age six it may look
vulnerable okay II five yeah you've
invited me too many times to push my
pole in the center he five is what I
want to see happen yeah this is this is
a position that is as you said it's it's
flexible for black and often often
played as we mentioned by Grandmaster
Cara Nakamura but in in a position of
very well per player well-prepared
strong players there's a lot of risk in
these positions with the king of the
center white having total control over
the pawn break throughs you want to you
want to get d5 in here if you're white
but right now you're you got a lot of
things to calculate as far as captures
to d5 feels right I mean I it's a move I
would play like probably too quickly
just sort of trusting the the craziness
of the position I might even play d5 and
on Knight g3 just take e6 you know and
just go all-in on the fact that white
has the big center and trust my activity
to expose the on Castle King okay
interesting moon Queen III clearly
didn't want to commit to pushing that
pawn there a lot of tactics there and do
you think that it's pasta products not
trusting his tactical vision right now
yeah I don't know and he's he's
obviously down on the clock - so he's
calculating he's trying to calculate
whether it works rather than kind of
trusting the intuition of the position
the bishop pair yeah I guess he's only
down one game in the match and if he was
down by more games I think he would've
played d5 but because he just have the
gap from two games to one I think he's
taking it safe rather than risky too
much because he feels himself inching
closer to tying this match up right so
just trying to get a little
psychological here no I think I think
you're totally right and obviously you
know you believe you can win any match
but then when you may be doing it right
you get it maybe a little nervous wait
he takes d4 we take an f3 first oh we
didn't know he doesn't but now I can
take with the night and these pawns are
just horrible you know I mean the G
pawns aren't anything to look at either
but I would say mmm I was gonna but
Queen d3 and there he goes but also 85
is a consideration to either say I'm
going to hurt your Queens at pawn
structure or if you go d5 about 94 to c5
gives up the Jeep Oh his d4 is hanging
at the end yeah wait Queen g6 you you
have Queen g6 and if Queen g6 knight c6
Bishop d4 but you don't I just take you
in d4 and if ruk takes rook takes you
have 9 f8 and you're just better in the
endgame I guess I mean I'm worried about
rook d2 at the end of some of those
lines with the long-distance thing
happened on g2 right yeah I guess you
may have been right maybe he should have
gone for that Queen c4 it's kind of a
nice simple move you hit c7 you also hit
e6 now you have all these worries about
when that Knight moves there's
discoveries on the e pawn yeah see if I
could just take it though this is the
second time Danny we've seen way you do
this right unleashing c5 move yeah
maybe questionable if we're talking
about a class right in when a blitz game
really puts the onus on Prague to find
tactics very quickly I would say I agree
with you though just take on c5 yeah I
think you take it and the point everyone
is that if we analyze it I'll show you
here that if d c5 rook d1 the point is
that Y can take with the night and leave
the rook protecting the centralized pony
but look at that Prague plays the move
d5 instead I don't like them
and Wow okay if I takes Knight takes you
can't take me five because of night of
six double check winning the Queen yep
and what oh I'll just refuge 75 takes
Knight takes King h7 just laughing in
the face of the ponies yeah they're both
pinned
they're both hit it's ridiculous yeah
you could play Knight of three and
defend the brook honey one unpinning
that's true right f7 problem in your
other night double pin double rainbow
where is Pete Carroll when you need him
Pete Carroll he's too busy getting us C
championship titles oh sorry
and MC no sorry that's us see national
champions in college oh you know the
Reggie Bush era well when you're a
college who buys players that's easy to
do right all right King age 7 okay this
is the line wheel okay it's happening
right right exactly as we thought it
would and I don't know if that spells
good things for for prog though but he
is gonna be up a pawn despite the
bishops being nasty in an end game yeah
I like that move Queen c7 hitting g3 and
the night on b6 here comes Queen takes
g3 I don't think Prague saw this coming
Ricky 747 visa so roomy sevens a nice
counter shot here be fine my gosh he
finds it with less than 10 seconds this
is super complex and we've seen frog in
the upper who's Ian times win these
games so far everyone if you're just
joining us most of these crazy scrambles
have gone the way of the the young man
from India wait seven takes b7 it's
happening where he doesn't have a
knockout what's a queen up to check is
gonna be a threat or is between up to
check King h19 was yeah there's nothing
there's nothing there's no Queen takes
Queen rook takes h3 no queening green
guards h4 oh he blundered
though he sees working for Burger King
silver you miss queen takes a four
negative six check puzzle rush me oh my
gosh that would have been nasty I will
show it as soon as the game is over
don't go anywhere
there was puzzle rush meet there there
may still be some sort of puzzle rush
you miss queeny one there Brogdon honda
has tied the match let me show you let
me show you what just happened in this
position crazy but it wasn't was it made
Queen takes up 409 f6 check and you
bring the other work into d8 yes oh my
gosh that would have been so nasty and
even in the game continuation day after
Queen e7 check back to f7 yeah
Queen e1 which one is way back to e1
defending everything and guarding h4 via
the x-ray defense meaning you guard it
through your opponent's piece oh my god
oMG Tsar snaps but guess what we have a
tied match regardless of how that broke
down we just freaked out can we just
talk about it for a second because I
need the moment to catch my breath
Dani we just lost it well well well
wow wow chicka wow wow by the way one of
the worst soundtracks to a movie ever
Will Smith and Wild Wild West but ok
doesn't matter we have nearly 9,000 of
you and another gift bomb coming at us
from but 7 spiders answering the
question will Dini become spider-man
because he got bit by a spider last
night find out next find out next time
oh my god dude we have a kite Mac that
was crazy
so it's what we've been talking about
Danny every time there's been a bullet
brawl situation been all prog ways yes I
am three different games three get ever
happened speeches championship history
we're smarter than chess
where's our stack I don't know well I
mean we've had upsets before this would
be for sure I mean a couple of years ago
in March Madness UMBC a perennial
powerhouse for chess yeah upset a
one-seed I don't know I mean it seems so
crazy to imagine that that could be the
case but right now have we ever seen so
many flags
in a speech at I don't think so I can't
remember three flags and the truth is
both sides have had a much more stable
connection than that which they started
with if you're just joining us nearly
9,000 of you there were more connection
issues these guys are joining us from
China and India respectively but they
seem to have very stable connections
right now it's just been that Prague has
been getting the better of the 2750 Wei
Yi in the time scrambles and just just
crazy crazy stuff and again there's
about 9,000 of you with us if you're
watching this on chefs comm click
through come to twitch and hit that
purple follow button and let's remind
you why we have you of who we're dealing
with here who are these two players that
you're watching in front of you
well pregnant Nanda is a rising star
from India and he's the fourth youngest
Grand Master in history
he's the 16 seat if you're talking speed
Chess Championship so he is the underdog
as underdog as it can get here against
Wei Yi who was my pick to win the whole
thing I think I'm looking a little bit
silly right now III don't know that this
sort of blitzen time scramble skill
would keep up with someone like all the
reason firoozeh but that's another story
even if he doesn't get by this guy and
and speaking of Wei Yi he's uh he is the
one seed but he's got his work cut out
for him right now in a deadlock match he
says he loves puzzle rush but he's
missing tactics in the time scramble
Robert might be time to go back to the
puzzle rush drawing board yeah and he
said his weakness is positional I think
it's all on the clock and they are many
situations here three times he's lost on
time and right now with the white pieces
he's down 12 seconds and I keep looking
at the clock because of what we've seen
and I would take on a seven he just has
done that and bishops hasty Oh didn't
take on c4 I thought he's gonna try to
ruin his problems trying to ruin ways
pawn structure bishop takes four earlier
but def plays like this and why he's
gonna try to clamp down the position
played a pony on b6 which means I've
rook on 87 look a little silly okay rook
on 87 hitting a5 but he invited Knight
b6 with tempo I was just saying how
Knight b6 what white won't do anyway
so there's a little strange to me to
invite Knight b6 like that black ocean
is not fun here because you really want
to open up your bishops they need open
diagonals but we're like f5 as it was
just
late night a fort is what I would play
in response I look at yourseif upon how
you gonna protect because after rook c8
after 984 I think I go Queen b6 the rook
on a seven Thunder attack they move
you're up be seven falls so it looks
like white is giving the upper hand here
Knight d5 is also I think based on the
b7 pawn being crucial Robert let's
analyze it here because I think the
point is that if Bishop d5 edie rook d5
and Queen b6 rook e8 Queen b7 and white
just thinks the endgame is good maybe be
good back on d5 Bishop e5 take Brad
I was about to say Queen d7 is way
better
great move it it prevents this idea of
Queen coming to b6 and just punching the
rook away from defending the b-pawn and
and actually threatens to take the the
d5 pawn with the Queen in a lot of
positions so this is uh I like it also
black can consider play E for at some
moment just to say yeah I really want to
open a bish one g7 so if you go I don't
see a way to protect d5 do you I don't
see any way well you're not really gonna
take it right away probably because the
Queen b6 and a similar idea we've been
talking about but the problem for Wei Yi
is you got to find a move and now we see
that the that the top seed there from
China getting down on the clock and it
was interesting because we saw
foreshadowings of this even when way he
was up three games in the match that the
scrambles were going to Prague and he
has got to find himself on the clock
here if your wayi cuz if he keeps
getting himself under time pressure we
may see that incredible upset yep and
from t8 but so quickly you know just
took this point 85 background check
means you can't take b7 because because
row K what is mate oh gosh way he is
tilting so ok now we just okay h6 can be
played can I go up or just to stop room
taking on b7 as well yeah right there's
oh but actually if I don't eat for you
might go g3 in Summerlin played Bishop
f4 but may I go Bishop
it's in complicated I don't want that
kind of complication so I probably start
with water if he was looking at even
something like b5 you don't want to
trade everything and win to d5 pawn if
Queenie
is devastating but maybe frog is trying
to find some way to simplify the
position at some point taking a lot of
time here not not to be oh and he ends
up going for b5 I was looking at that
and and he decides he's not afraid of
Queen e8 I'm maybe I shouldn't I guess
is just equal right Queenie Bishop and
famous reach six yeah I thought though
Bishop h6 Queen f7
oh you can't take e5 obviously because
aged six falls yeah so Queen f7 he gets
away with it
right as we might Queen somewhere I keep
the pin alive so whether this was the
right idea or not I was looking at this
and thinking that this would be the way
to just take away your opponent's
counter play and that's what Prague
decided to do I think he's just sorry
Evan King up seven now yeah you should
take it on that feet oh he can do that
picking up seven anyways oh no he can't
so Queen d7 chat just give a check there
Queen b7 first there should be seven
Mobley I'm gonna keep pinning you that's
all I want to do is just like keep the
situation the status quo and look at
blacks times seven seconds
yeah probably getting down on time so
not sure this was the best practical
approach even if he did simplify it a
little bit now you starting e4 though I
mean so f3 h 6h 6 and e4 yeah did not
like G 0 f3 to stop before you put it
down and it was a good move so now see 4
meter plate c4 babyyyy nobody look out
for the end game but taken himself can't
take on he said I'd washer who was
better in the king queen be a chick who
we just miss Queenie hey that was
winning time oh no oh my gosh Oh what he
leans back he knows he blundered it
that's it yeah that's it he had to keep
his king close to that bishop oh my gosh
the Queen comes to e8 with devastating
effects and we will show you exactly why
that was a blunder here he missed it not
once but twice you have to put the King
on f7 but he didn't want to allow the
Queen to come to h8 he was worried about
this which for good reason cuz probably
white is at least drawing there so black
had clearly already got himself in
trouble with this king coming out but
the second time way he had a chance he
finds Queen e8 and he wins a piece
because the bishop was a penny mote on
the e6 Queen everybody Wow
amazing stuff
Wow and look at look at way in this game
after kind of well not kind of he was
very fortunate in that last game now
he's going for each six g5 early push
and just I mean look at this he's going
real aggressive in night h4 as the net
responds I guess Knight takes e4 is that
possible I don't know this line at all
but I guess whoa he's good we're gonna
find out if it's possible he's going for
it I think probably wondered he plays f4
the crook is hanging on he was just
blunders at four I say no like I feel
like a dad right now I'm like no son
I've not brought dad I'm not rooting for
anyone but that's just hard to see the
blunder happen you ain't just pointed it
out to maybe just point out you can't
take it the Queen cuz the rook I'm not
even gonna back up and show it again if
you missed that tactic that's a you
problem right now but shout out to all
9,000 of you with us we've had a lot of
gifted subs coming in haven't been able
to call attention to all of them but we
appreciate your support a lot of premium
members hanging on the chest TV chat as
well and thank you all for being here
Oh M Jesus naps he has bounced back now
if you're just joining us we've actually
seen this happen whyyyy was up three
games in the match Prague came back with
a couple victories in a row and then way
he went on a run of his own this has
definitely been a match of mini runs
right Robert where they're just kind of
stopping each other back and forth and
and now after having tied up the match
at five Prague Nenana has lost frankly
to two pretty bad games right just
blunders yeah especially the game that
made him go from a five five tie into a
six five deficit he was one better that
game he was up with Yellin he had that
poem d5 locked down and he just really
blundered in the last critical moment
and here I like way he strategy he's up
two games he's playing a position where
black has concrete weaknesses and why
you're just gonna go try the time on
Queen c2 just going after that c5 pawn
and if black ever plays before you just
strategically totally busted because
I'll put my knight from d2 to b3 where
an attack is ipon and very importantly a
black knight cannot get to d4 very
easily because we let me handle
doesn't show that real quick so that
people understand the idea of let's
won't say it right now if black ever
tries to close the structure this is the
last thing you want to do and you have
these kind of weaknesses why can slow
play you go Jamie Foxx on this slow jam
the pressure on c5 you even had a six
and Brooke a five if you let me do it
but don't want to create no tension when
you're the person with the worst pawn
structure you need the tension to exist
for the opportunity that it might change
right so that's why you even see a weird
move like Bishop a six here you're just
doing everything you can to not settle
on either taking c4 where you have
doubled isolated pawns or or playing b4
and leaving these pawns horribly weak so
but again I like I like a youth position
as well Robert I agree with you this
just looks like Prague has put himself
on tilt here with a couple of bad losses
and he's gonna be worse than this one
for a while yeah I was wondering if it's
someone he can play b4 it seems like a
strategic blunder a lot having better
word but at some point what sorry black
triplet for f5 in some of these lines
now it's very far-fetched idea because
it tastes you tonight then play f5 opens
up the g5 Square for the bishop so okay
now 97 for sure yep same idea 9c 76 okay
I was like yeah he wants to come here or
traditional 97f 86 I'm like what is he
doing 98 no same idea we come to the e6
square and hopefully land on d4 yep and
by hopefully we're definitely landing on
d4 you can't stop Wow that was it
aggressive definitely by you I love that
would you get passionate and Hikaru says
in the chat that's why Knight d2 met B
to d2 to b3 was needed instead of b3
just spoke about that idea yeah okay
because the knight will be stuck on d7
that's actually a great point yeah
that's right yeah now all of a sudden
where he's taken I think because he
doesn't had the plan of bringing the
knight a forest is too slow based on the
idea we've been talking about too weak
to slow the night will come to e6 this
is one way to what he's trying to do
everyone who's trying to prevent 94 cuz
the Queen pins the pawn on c5 to the
lady on a 77
I'm not even sure it really stops Knight
d4 actually but it's it's part of the
idea of rook d3 I like that move Knight
a 4 am I just gonna take on c4 yep I
love it
whoa we're gonna find out you know I
would like to even more than rook to e3
is Bishop f8 just so I could go 94 next
oh you can still play with your fate now
and that pawns not going anywhere of an
e5 no e 5 hanging aah
yeah so this is looking less favorable
than it did a moment ago bitter takes c4
still looks a good move to me I could
black be worse there well he's also up
on the clock so he has some time to
think about it this is why you try to
play fast in your opponent so when the
critical moment comes you have a little
bit more time to think I think there's a
couple options here Robert there's rook
to b8 where you might trade everything
on c5 and try to win the b3 pawn the
old-fashioned way but you got to worry
about a 7 falling in a lot of positions
okay so or there's the move we already
talked about Bishop c4 ignore that
mission Queen b7 young Queen d7 or b7 I
like b7 just pile up pressure on that b3
pawn yep there it is interesting why did
you take on c5 with the bishops of the
night because now you're 984 is just
silly over there
yeah fun master Mike would say pile up
pressure on the pin piece PP on the pp
for those of you who don't watch chess
kit videos you should and for those of
you who don't like having equal material
take on b3 there you go for those of you
who like winning position though are you
gonna keep the for those of you going
you know don't want to trade rooks and
improve your pawns Queen you like Queen
b5 yeah for those of you who just joined
the guys welcome to the juniors feat
Chess Championship for those of you
wondering where Roberts beard went in it
went away because of the charity stream
idea we thankfully we raised it $1,900
for those of you wondering what MBL's
gonna shave on camera we have a new show
launching at some point called adopted
Danny where he's gonna try to adopt me
in every different time control all the
different disciplines of blitz I'm
actually not kidding about that and he
will shave on camera well that's
speechless anyway for those of you
wondering
before it looks really really good and
for those of you wondering why this yo
got out of hand I don't know why but
they always happen when me and Robert
are hosting together thanks for being
here go to chest comm TV or twitch.tv
slash chest hit the follow button follow
us so that you get alerts when we go
live this yeah black has played well and
a prog is is trying to to right the ship
here look that [__] money to so strong
rook da just keep pressure baby looks
really good f3 you can't take with a
nice brick d8 is just like all my pieces
working together right have three just
play it and redo it
oh if we would have opened up the g5
square for the Queen to Oh after you
look so three in Queens you five that's
just winning right f3f3f3 and then you
play Bishop h6 or Queens g5 it's calling
it's calling my name I can feel it
coming in the air tonight no take on c4
oh he's missing his chances to put it
away this f3 move has been now Knight f3
there's no there's this is not a
lights-out position anymore feels pretty
good though yeah put the rook on e8 I
guess and okay but still I mean there's
there's been whatever there's chances to
win Robert you often say you can lose
games by missing opportunities right
100%
the longer you know your point stay in
the game this 97 looks in the land down
97 is coming there's a time scramble the
second blunders we could almost feel it
coming Bob just really let this one get
away this is one that's gonna hurt if we
are remembering a big moment in the
match honestly this might have been this
might have been one that really got away
because we would wonder back we should
be we should be too
oh my gosh white one's coming to d1 and
who's winning I don't know okay take
your plate no you can't take a play
rugby one Knight comes lucky to you
blunder that you should have been ripped
rip d1 right away it's a vision 83
okay mister c3 Bishop d2 seal play
rabbinic now now white is finally
he's losing a piece back 56 56 and he's
holding no time on the clock
what is it black should be better here
right the 86 font feels weak
yeah but the 87 pawn is also key file
okay black is better blacks better the
a6 pawn will because this has been in
literally a topsy-turvy affair 97 oh my
god twice they've listed take 96 use it
outside passed pawn and note that the H
pawn and the bishop don't win together
so in weapon tonight is that the knight
is the trickier piece here of course and
if you could trade the night for the
like all the pawns and leave the black
with an H font it's intriguing to be for
instead no is he gonna just play tickle
6 he's running away
there should be 694 check King c3 what's
the answer I don't know so there should
be 6 then move your King into the 85 is
now is now coming why didn't he do it I
don't know who's king of note no oh my
gosh it doesn't work he's all laying on
the idea to draw tv6 f4 you got a
playoff for and stop your place what no
g5 King g6 now he blundered g4 and then
F 64 and it's the wrong color bishop oh
but just a draw
oh my gosh he can't stop h4 no that game
was a rollercoaster of emotions I am not
equipped for this I'm tuning for this
bleep
my brain hurts oh my gosh no seriously
that was that was crazy like I I want to
back up and show some things but I
honestly have no idea what to show
because there were so many moments where
both players missed massive
opportunities but but right here
probably one of the biggest ones King f6
definitely definitely the easier way to
win I mean the piece a could not have
worked but even earlier they were
winning opera all I know is that there
were so many moments that just happened
I'm gonna rely on the community to maybe
clip it remember anybody we do have a
moment of the match so clip your
favorite things that happen and maybe
your clip will be chosen for a moment of
the match and so ridiculous that
that was a game full of potential
moments of the match right both sides
letting it get away from them at
different points and again if you if you
saw some exciting stuff clip it for us
share it in the twitch chat you can
share it on social media if you're into
that too but we will have a moment of
the match at some point chosen later on
here today was unbelievable and you know
I guess God move on to the next game if
you're pregnant I'm done here in this
game
why is he thinking is he trying to
sacrifice accra price again efore with
night age four I thought it was going
ninety-one as a whole point of not
putting your Brooke on e1 was giving you
a night that's square another night eats
before what's his plan as a response is
he gonna go for the f3 idea that he just
came up with before well on the bright
side he's not gonna blunder a ruck like
he did the game before right yeah which
was also a big moment of the match crazy
crazy crazy stuff I almost said crazy
sauce which is also a thing you can put
on your wings delicious yep f4 plate
again this time maybe a little bit more
accurate I still don't have a lot of
faith in this line but is there
something about this line we just don't
know on a theory level I found black and
playing f5 and thinking about the rest
later
because everything else looks terrible
just giving my opponent a free attack f5
gives me a counter chance right I'm
attacking your knight on e4 yes I can't
cast a king side but if I get Bishop d7
council Queen side in you're just down
on so I'm really proud black but nope
that's not good but I like f5 now for
white and five is just a very good move
you clamp you clamp the light squares if
I move like this is trade you could take
with both the Queen and the pawn and
everyone and still be in good shape but
you take with the Queen though because
you can't Castle queenside without f7
right okay big questions facing Prague
now on how to handle this but we also
have a daily question a lot of you have
been getting involved on social media
okay he plays that five let's run
everybody what that question was not too
late to give us your answer for a chance
to win a diamond membership what is the
greatest hermit performance of all time
by a junior robber and I'm still waiting
for you to pick one but now we have one
coming at us from at Jeff Owens he says
I'd vote for Pogue are sisters and the
28th chess olympiad Judah was just 12
when they won the event that's that's a
really good one that's a pretty good one
and
reminds me of a great book Judah
Judith's book series that she's been
releasing kind of a bit of an
autobiography she talked about that
whole experience and obviously Judah
does amazing things for chess we had
that that's got to be up there that's a
great one there good pick I'm curious to
see if anyone comes up with any other so
all right thank you doing what Thank You
something mine now you want yours now
yeah start listening that's our daily
question give us your answers on social
media but go ahead Robert as we play
this one out
so Billy Barty but winning the World
Junior with a perfect 11 no score okay
Bobby Fischer when he well juniors under
21 or under 18 under 21 that was I'm 21
Bobby Fischer win team in 1960 36 before
US Championship with a perfect score
that might be a real winner a single
greatest individual performance yeah
that's right and he was they were and
that US Championship was stacked we're
chefs key and a whole lot of them so
Magnus Carlsen in was it the pearl
spring tournament in 2009 I think his
performance ring was over 3,000 so right
arts argue with that kind of greatness
and I do you would be a wealth of
knowledge on this question
Oh upon Amara winning the not feat a
knockout when he was 19 right he was
under 21 in Las Vegas right what happens
in Vegas doesn't stay in Vegas or eov
for a slump ponomaryov did did things
that not many juniors have ever done I
mean it technically that was a world
championship title right the first ever
one of its kind defeating knockout at
that time was not not on par with the
classical world championship title as it
as it isn't now but it was I think even
even more prestigious then so can we
talk about something else for Jimmy not
said I don't want you to say I just
looked at the board while we're talking
with this no no I want to go back to the
board - those are some great answers but
yeah position for we today this is a
horrible position I want I want a puzzle
rush mate like I want nothing
this is look so bad wait is he about to
go bishop seed 98 and reset the pieces
EA tonight be eight okay you're not even
threatening to take on at five cuz he
eights mate dude you know I don't want
talking abut Danny I was thinking the
same exact thing about like there's no
threat here even H threes a move for
white oh no it's not
because takes there's made on g2 don't
blow there made an okay 97 also works we
know that helps an umbrella pong I
thought he was winning material but he
doesn't even have any follow-ups
there's no an umbrella pon highlighted
by Robert let's back up and analyze that
to show everybody what he's talking
about you don't want to create a
scenario where your own pawns block your
activity and an umbrella is used when we
describe your opponent's pawn kind of
blocking you from the rain hitting you
this pawn white would love to just take
it off the board but the fact that it's
there actually makes blacks defense a
little easier okay like that I think
because you're getting rid of some of
your pawns open up more lines and so
this has become much more of a crazy
scramble that it was previously Bishop
g5 you have to keep this e71 I think I'm
looking at the clock I'm thinking about
the fact that this one has already gone
away from him I'm liking where you to
hold this maybe do better to two pawns I
thought I was young wait okay Queen Oh
Queen takes b3 b7 was hanging yeah I'm
very confused by this game on c5 no nice
game but there's threats on c6 it's not
okay broke a5 Queen trade oh my gosh
yep that's huge and Black's gonna go on
to win this game now is your g5 you have
to take this is just gonna put a piece
on e5 yeah rook comes to e5 you force
the trade and white really let this one
get away progress definitely had his
chances over the last few games but it's
just miss playing multiple moments yeah
this is very upsetting for the young
Indian Grandmaster because he's had some
really good games and this looked like
it was about to be one of those where
wait he played really badly and he was
playing well and then all of a sudden he
let him slide the h4 pawn falls this is
an easily winning rook ending just way
too many pawns you're up to and the ones
that are left are also pretty bad you
and just now the night goes back and
that's safety Rugnetta fate would force
force the rooks off the board he finds
it and that's gonna be at Prague is
sitting back in his chair shaking his
head he knows he let this one yet again
get away from him so it's been it's been
I mean hard to find what the biggest
moment in this three minute portion
really is as far as when a slipped away
from Prague nonde but you can't say he
hasn't had opportunities so he's had
many opportunities now we're in the
Fabiano Caruana magnus carlsen world
championship match again we've seen
opening several times the Rasul emo and
okay I think probably actually has shown
pretty good play in this opening in fact
the game they just drew two games ago
where Prague was completely winning it
shows some good understanding of the
position in some critical moments and
right now I you know we see this time
and time again if I'm black you play f6
you play Knight h6 a knight upset that's
one way of playing of course you wanted
to play neither of 697 either fate 96
and just bring the next to e6
essentially so that way go to d4 but
that's not feasible when the e5 pawn is
hanging right away yeah and I just I
don't know I'm biased toward liking the
structure for white I know that Prague
dig fate did figure it out the last time
he had it but positionally I like
white's chances and these and these ones
so how do you go for this now are you
playing for the the typical kind of b3
bring the bishop to this side of the
board at least d3 he's trying him do his
thing again with Bishop e3 queen b 1b
for ideas something like that here it
comes
but it is a bit slow for white and if
you play a 5 is why i go be fed with a
tempo now and the c5 phone isn't weak
enough to exploit and black can actually
find like dat 6 as well but the
plaintiff I was gonna say the plan of
Queen b1 with C 3 and B 4 black can
never really put the stop on it with a 5
because b6 falls although oh now maybe
he'll he'll get rid of that night on c4
and change change that thing and
whenever you play c3 though at D
upon is immediately much more at five is
a possible hour no it's too it's too
soon too soon
no no not too soon he plays a fight that
was a first argument of the day and well
frog settled that won my favor okay but
it's 'if I've really really defensible I
guess the main point is you can take c4
if things open up takes on f5 will
analyze it here real quick if takes I
guess you're taking with the pawn or
actually maybe the bishop not sure
and then for d8 here maybe I take with
the bishop and then bring the rook over
this is tough call Dan you pretty rook
endear you well yeah he did take with
the pawn and then on b3 he's still gonna
bring the rook over but it's hard to
decide which will become the bigger
weakness the e5 pawn with everything
ganging up on it or the d3 pawn at some
point or the b3 pawn at some point
yeah and already is it tough this one
probably taking his time the tough
decision between work a to d8 over LTE
now usually you wanna play from F to e
eight and then a to d8 and your ups in
the center but here your rook on a phase
on a good file because you've already
pushed your pawns forward so you want to
cook there to help both defend your
pawns and maybe to help launch them
forward at the right moment efore FTC
for Euro haven't open file to work with
visual t5 actually like a lot that's a
good move yeah that's a great move
threatening to take a free note
everybody something like 92 actually
doesn't run into f4 because of bishop
takes up four but don't trap your Bishop
Queen f6 here nice C to D - and now
Queen f6 would renew the threat of f4
and it also gives you some efore ideas
where c3 pawn me so weak and he finds it
Queen f6 this it's just consistently
done well in the transition from opening
to middle game it's where a lot of the
out playing has happened early stages in
the middle game and but again you can't
keep saying that he's playing well
because the scoreboard talks and
everything else walks right you got to
convert on some of these positions
although now here comes f4 and Bishop
takes h3 just again pregnant Honda on
the attack and actually f4 also now
[__] of a [__] you're right out of that
Danny I've worked a 2d and how you gonna
protect d3 so Queen Dziedzic is a double
attack in the sense of H 3 and D 3 and
this looks terrible
four-way and this is a big game for
probably nonde because he went from
being tied 5 to 5 tonight we have three
games if he can keep within 2 points in
that striking distance I think he has
amazing chances in the bullet because
boys everyone hasn't been particularly
great in time travel thus far
though his credit he did win that game
where he was down upon with a queen e8
winning the bishop so he has had some
time scrambles success even feels like
overall it's been all Prague when the
clock starts ticking low yeah we'll see
if he can win another time scramble wand
really Gasol and the chess TV chat says
so many viewers 9k of them plus on
Twitch for these two generational
talents but we've had we got a whole
lineup of generational talents to remind
you of who's coming up next here and the
junior speeches championship we've got
Sam seve on vs. Niehaus are in the
country minute Prague nonde who's been
in the twitch chat for a good part of
the day not sure if Niehaus still there
if you are say hey buddy hey car will
give Andy Howell a shout out there but
Sam Savion vs. Niehaus aren't on June
3rd that's coming up mark your calendar
now those are our next two talents who
will be throwing down here so thank you
a wand Riga soul and everybody at the
chest comp TV chat as well as everyone
on Twitch Oh
d3 falls yeah welcome that rook to the
d3 square free pawn now Bishop takes h3
is a renewed threat with FQ hang even
Zack in the exchange is almost a renewed
threat this position is getting really
rough ER for way yeh alright hope takes
c3 speaking of a second exchange
somebody for just a winning threat ah
yeah that's that's uh that'll be lights
out this is bad bad news and it carves
as he assumes that we missed from 9h
forever takes h3 check winning the Queen
yeah yeah that must have been the key
and let's analyze that to show everybody
what hit car was talking about likely
when he allowed the move d3 it was
quickly calculated that night h4 because
indeed not h4 would remove the Queen
from protecting the rook but as a car
pointed out way he probably missed rook
takes H
which is a check and then the queen
falls on c2 so yeah I'm gonna guess that
her car was right about that because no
way you just give up the d3 pawn for
free okay Wow
wait taking and then playing e4 is this
is this gonna be a no no we missed now
now Prague misses the reverse but oh my
gosh and he shakes his head yep he
missed that the world takes e4 just get
desperate you got to get desperate the
point everybody let's analyze it again
and show everybody what he just okayed
the ecig what he miss is exactly what
you're seeing the e6 Bishop is falling
at the end of the line so maybe no
reason to analyze it cuz it's on the
board and it shows exactly why Prague
Nenana blundered super unfortunately Wow
almost like this and again he's now
about he's now been clearly better like
I would say winning you know in the long
time which he'll in three games in a row
Robert you know and he just hasn't
converted so pregnant is gonna go down
he just made that move with 0.2 seconds
but regardless he's losing he's losing
on the board and on the clock and and
this this four-game lead for Wei Yi
which really really getting outside of
the realm of possibilities of comebacks
you know you probably not it's got to
stop the bleeding right now but it's
been it's been a hard one to swallow if
you're an in camp Prague because he's
been better in a lot of games ya know
that game was his for the taking
completely winning he found from taste
III I found this Queen g6 maneuver with
after f5 he played very very well but
you're right there's a certain point
claim well is not a consolation box
you're just yep you're down four games
in the scoreboard and you're eliminated
if you don't win this match so he needs
to kind of gather himself and find a way
to just to get them knockout blow if I
we've seen this line with h6g five
things in several games where it's been
good for him and he's just blundered it
away so yeah you just needs to convert
he's having trouble converting his
winning position and Danny that was
shocking part is he's had more time in
many of those games
yep so well when it comes to young
players competing in this format we
never quite know what they're capable of
I see a lot of people already
speculating
how good either of these guys will be in
bullet of course with the increment in
the speech s championship format always
kind of ensures that the chest will do
the talking and the time scramble will
be kind of the second part of it but but
still I think as the the time gets less
progress has has done good in those
scrambles but but now he's really
missing opportunities so it's you know
hard for me to predict who's gonna have
the edge in bullet right now you know
like hey carvers point here basically
wait he was out playing him early and
losing time scrambles now Prague is
playing well who blundering in time
scrambles first no it's been a reversal
of roles in the three-minute portion if
you're just joining us been a very back
and forth match though this match was
tied at five games apiece but since then
obviously as you can see where ye has
won four and a half of the next five
games despite Prague being better and
many of them so again don't go anywhere
if you're watching this at chess comm
via the homepage you happen to see that
it was live and and and unmuted thank
you for joining us but head over to
twitch.tv slash chess and give the give
the biggest channel here on twitch a
follow for you so that you can follow
these these chess events when they go
live and get alerts all right this
position I also like for white because I
feel strongly about this attack that's
brewing over there on the queenside
night g3 see that's a move that he
percent 22 seconds on and to move that
I'm positive hit car would have played
in two seconds and obviously Hikaru and
Goro might have gained two seconds yeah
it cars next up but the thing is Nike do
you feels like a pretty obvious move and
b5 might have been a good move so there
are times when you have to kind of find
your shot but in this moment right now
your position looks good for light
because you always have the threat of
the attack so Castle can't just cancel
like I know that I might have something
on the queenside but I also know that
I'm up 20 seconds on the clock and way
he has shown that he gets himself in
time trouble and gets an actually real
trouble right time drove because he has
long in times three games so it's hard
to sacrifice quality of play for
quantity on the clock
but in this matchup articular I think
way he is showing vulnerability in the
time scramble so I would
trying to keep taking advantage yeah I I
was I was kind of in a trance if you
were talking to that was just love it
every word you said I agree totally and
I think that we highlight that a lot
that playing perfect chess is not
necessarily the recipe to winning these
matches getting your opponent under time
pressure just as important as the
quality of the moves are making many
many times and look at I said 44 seconds
on Castle
which is a movie definitely saw it
instantly and that I was pushing for a
while ago and I'm not trying to be
overly critical of a very strong teenage
run master like he's an exceptional
player and he doesn't have the
experience likely of the this format
where you and I have a commentary time
and time again so we see how players
start taking advantage of their ponies
weaknesses he's just trying to find the
best moves which is all credit to him
he's playing really well but in critical
moments when you have 12 seconds left it
becomes very difficult absolutely well
the rook games to e8 and again Wei Yi is
as speeding up although actually I'm
looking at the time logs here that you
can see on chess calm both sides have
really taken time 30 seconds then 22
seconds 22 seconds 23 seconds just
respectively both these guys are really
really not sure how they want to handle
this critical moment and now now we're
gonna we're gonna see a lot of a lot of
action here get ready for this position
to get wild he's yeah makes you okay
Knight takes e4 like that by just taking
d4 seems like a straightforward way for
black to win a pawn what am I missing
before here Bishop takes and you're
taking with the tempo I was calculating
Knight takes let's analyze it and show
that after the Knight had taken if the
knight had taken this was the line I was
thinking that black would win a pawn but
okay we expect white will probably take
with the bishop and DD does after takes
Knight takes this will be the position
we have on the board and where's the
Queen going I'm money I might even say
gonna be five instead of on e4 after
Bishop takes d4 it because I go Knight
takes e4 back whoa whoa and now we see a
piece sacrifice way he takes on d4 is g3
hanging
some variations pawn look at this Bishop
pinning the f2 pawn a weakness of fun
master mike is he admitted on the show
the queen will threaten to take g3
Prague spots it quickly puts the king on
h1 and now we going pawn grabbing for
the piece III don't like this fur for
white this is bad for black
yeah Bishop 67 now rookie 7 night f5 and
yet simplify the position oh no ok why
is why he's not doing this correctly now
it's still in good shape
timing timepiece this Queen feels
awkward I thought maybe you would put a
piece on that 5 there and try to trade
it ooh okay maybe I'm wrong maybe he is
miss playing it yeah I think a piece out
of 5 would have been better yeah this
looks bad how much space is black my
guys what four pawns for the peace and
endless space on the board
pawns are just running up the board yeah
this is unfortunate for frog so he's
still in this dog take on at five oh I
was again a piece of the piece so if you
if you can if you can simplify you're
still up a minor but these two pawns are
looking more menacing by the second
here comes d3 Queen's come off the board
but these pawns are just way too strong
yeah they're very advanced honestly
especially with no time on the clock you
just you hate White's position here d2
or C to push one of them not sure if
this is a good thing for Prague Nenana
but he will get one more game in the
three minute portion after this I'm
guessing assuming that this one comes to
a close here before that three minute
now she lost connection oh my gosh
that's why he's frozen on camera way
he's gonna lose this one because of a
bad connection no way that is a momentum
changer in the match right there wow we
have a we have a bad connection
houston we have a problem the grant the
one seat from China has lost connection
he's gonna have to reestablish that as
quickly as he can he loses this one it
does count in the books and we're hoping
to get him back here and Prada also
looks kind of frozen Prague also looking
a little frozen we're gonna try to get
the players back here
so don't go anywhere right now as we
work on that Robert let's let's take a
second to talk about what we just saw
okay so from a psychological perspective
how do you handle that if your wayi a
game that your moments away from winning
now you lose right I guess you're still
up three games in the match so that's
your consolation prize yeah your dreams
the match and you realize you just
outplayed problem a very difficult
position where honestly it looked much
worse for you so you choose no comment
about your chess and it's one of those
games you can just like kind of mentally
get rid of after the match if you lose
the match because of a game that you're
really upset but during the match like I
mean whatever like I was completely
crushing my opponent I play better than
he did so I just keep playing like that
I think it actually psychologically
pretty easy - it's got to be the right
mindset anyway I mean you want a lot of
these guys are alright which they don't
suffer they actually are successful
because of short-term memory-loss right
they they want to forget their losses
very quickly and that comes when you're
a confident player with a lot of
experience right who knows what he's
doing you know you don't you don't dwell
on the past because it can really only
only be something that distracts you
from the present and all right so I
think that's probably true right now
we're trying to get these players back
so if you're with us don't go anywhere
we still got 9,000 of you crazy active
twitch chat with a couple of super
grandmasters fresh off the Grand Prix
and Moskva we've got Hikaru Nakamura and
Yonder pom Miyoshi yep thanks for being
here
well okay I mean Prague has Prague has
been much much better in this in this
match I think that then our cap score
for ticket I'll tell you that I mean
he's been in positions that he would win
I think if you were giving them more
time but that's part of the part of the
beast right you've got to be able to
handle the time scrambles as well we
will officially reset the game clock to
2 minutes and 48 seconds when the game
starts just so you know we we have a
whole staff team that keeps track of
these exact things behind the scenes and
right now we're trying to get both
back online so give us a few moments I
love dick Carver saying injury-time
+5 added to the bullet portion like his
paradise that's right please this is
like extra extra penalty time right
we've got we've got the bullet portion
coming right up as soon as the three
minute portion continues but these guys
are both trying to come back online
like we said Robert the prediction had
wayy kind of kind of increasing his lead
as the time which once got faster if
anything the opposite has been happening
but actually no I'm wrong no I guess ye
has been winning the Freeman abortion it
just hasn't necessarily been with the
cleanest of play right definitely I mean
play is never clean in speeches
championships although I have seen some
very clean Platt from the woman's speech
Chess Championship I saw some of those
matches very lopsided and deservedly so
they're just blenders everywhere as one
side really dominating but here I mean
this match could be nine F six and a
half and frogs favor it just slide
fortunate for him he's blundering some
crucial moments even though he got three
victory actually this is fourth victory
on time here comes the into mind
everybody that sorry I want to remind
everybody that we also have the women's
speeches championship going on a bit of
a break right now we actually just had
the first round come to a close with
Harika Drona volley taking down Maurice
a bhag yesterday and we will of course
start the semi-finals
later on in June but mark your calendars
make sure you're tuning in for the
Women's speeches championship as well
but like you said Robert this is
currently nine and a half six and
halfway ye probably could be the other
way if a few things swing but you know
what that's that's why they say
scoreboard is all that matters are wins
of win no matter how ugly it is right
yeah he's back he's back it seems like
the games have started but because I'm
I'm not a hundred percent sure yet let's
okay it looks like the other way but let
me mention everybody the tomorrow is
also a very very busy day here at twitch
TV slash chess we have the chess kid
games chess kit calm is our sponsor for
the juniors features championship if
you're one
what chess will be around tomorrow the
chess kid games will be underway we'll
talk a little bit about that and preview
who's in that later on in the show so
all right another closest Cillian Robert
but this time we're back to the the
Rasul mo the Moskva I like these lines
for white played Bishop c4 don't play
the name no this is not the good stuff
for white we still doesn't have a great
a great connection right now yeah it's
two bars yeah not ideal when bullets
coming up next so okay in these lines
for white you say I'm challenging the
center very early black is has less
development as you can see only two
pieces developed and well you did figure
out what to do about this knight on d4
situation at any moment I can take on d4
and encourage you to take your seat bond
which gains a semi-open C file but also
causes you to have this double pawn on
the D file which can become a big target
so this is how way he plays it I think
if you are probably non de you play it
was like d5 Bishop d7 or as well say e
697 then b5 made c6 to keep d4 safe but
c3 yep yeah this is this is the right
way for a white to transition what's a
six is committed because the idea is
that now the D file can be a bit of a
positional problem here for black you
could even take with the b-pawn and try
to use the diagonal as an issue but I
think D takes c3 is the more principled
move it's actually the reason why as
someone who plays e positions as black
Robert I agree with you I don't actually
I don't actually like the e6 move order
there because of this move c3 and now
now the D file is under White's control
yep
and well products that have played more
quickly so just now just go but Bishop
d7 I know your position position is not
very good
I definitely for white here a4 it comes
to mind
Queen d6 to take over a vulnerable dar
square right now Queen d6 looks quite
tempting what else can you do Bishop 26
looks good
the bishop coming in to f4 as well to
head into d6 looks good looks very very
pleasant yeah Queen d6 just feels good
feels right
and we now have one of the players back
with us Grandmaster Wei Yi we're aware
that the players are not on camera for
those of you yelling at us in chat we
are aware but right now we are focused
on the chess games continuing while the
players work to fix their their cameras
in the end the break that's coming up
right after this game actually we will
be headed into the bullet portion this
is officially the last three-minute game
of the match Queen B 697 I think even
even Bishop to g5 there Robert inducing
things like f6 is interesting yep please
okay a4 here just looks good because now
black is inviting Knight d4 with the
tempo on the bishop on c6 and the pond
yep
so this looks really ugly extremely ugly
there's a four yeah this is bad news for
Prague because you've got a very
fortunate win and now you're playing a
bad game this is a funny comment there
what's that it probably looks amazingly
still really really doing a great job
staying still that kid somebody had a
talking to him about bouncing around of
the chair you know you know people
always gue Nina said this for the woods
he just championship like the hardest
thing she learned was to sit on her
hands my koji humming Rock plate make
him move too quickly so sitting on your
hands the way to go so let's see well
Wei Yi is putting the pressure on him
Prague is down on the clock and doesn't
seem to be suffering from any connection
issues I think he's just suffering from
a bad position here right the old
fashioned way to lose a chess game
because this has just turned into a bad
open Sicilian and again for those of you
wondering where this kind of really
started going wrong it might be a little
early to say but this is a good tip that
in this particular line of the closest
ceiling to be very careful assuming that
this D file is going to stay close with
the movie six because as we saw white
opened it up and black was in positional
trouble really from from there on out
and so now finally way he goes from my
idea be 55
six and back and the point is you you
play tickle just to induce this pawn to
come to have six and block the bishop
and now you can play Bishop c5 okay with
the Queen trade being offered I'm sure
there's also a way to win material maybe
even taking and and eventually winning
the a6 pawn at the end of some of these
lines yep it was like he's gonna he's
gonna go for something like that before
now if you settle on brook a8 there's b5
if you cancel the a6 pawn Falls and so
this is kind of what we predict it
doesn't look very fun and blacks got no
development in the squares are still
weak the pony six is a weak so routines
a six here I don't even know how blacks
and respond to that Preston yeah this
just looks fantastic and so what you
called it Robert you said I mean how are
you gonna recover from that if your wayi
well you just short-term memory just
forget about it you were totally winning
which means you've been playing better
throughout most imagine you know you
just lost the game because of a
disconnect but win this one and you have
a four game lead headed into the last
segment this is no fun Bishop d4 rook
g8f for pawn at least is seems like it's
under attack but the d7 pawn feels weak
as well so officially III back seems
good is your E 5 yeah III if you think
this five if we start trading some pawns
and rook even though I'm down upon a
decent chance to hold and some engines I
yeah I think this is simple though
because now you can play g3 slowly bring
the king up and white is still the only
one who can win Wow never okay seven and
you just take t6 or Brook takes d6 right
away also good kills bad man feels bad
man way you doesn't even look that
thrilled about his position but I mean
he's he's crushing here he's about he's
like he's kind of stoic Lee like alright
I guess I'll take another pawn alright I
guess I'll beat you on time whatever
well I guess that's going to take us to
our our next break the players have
rematch but we will abort it and let
them know that this is their last chance
to get some fresh air maybe a juice box
I don't know juice box juice box can I
get a juice box
juicebox right I would love us to thank
everybody who's with us say don't go
anywhere because this has been a match
full of tons of back-and-forth obviously
we have a four-game lead right now for
the favorite not an insurmountable one
though in Bullitt I think that combined
connection issues and your skepticism of
what's going to hold up there with the
fact that Prague has been playing pretty
good chess
he's just been just been letting it slip
in some critical moments so don't go
anywhere the juniors features
Championship presented by chess kit calm
heads to the bullet portion when we
return
[Music]
Fisher random chess a game were
creativity is King and memorization
impossible 960 different back rank
configurations from the world's best
chess players into mere competitors
trying to outwit and outclass each other
with every unprepared move only one will
be worthy of the title of Fisher random
chess champion but the best part is that
champion could be you the Fisher random
Chess Championship will be unlike any
tournament ever held with a global
qualification system for the first time
ever
everybody truly has a chance to prove
themselves the best player in the world
at a chess variant are you a chess
artist worthy of the 11th world
champions admiration we're gonna find
out the tournament features open
qualifiers beginning on April 28th and
the title player qualifier stage
beginning in June over $300,000 Fabiana
Caruana Nakara Nakamura and world
champion Magnus Carlsen await you at the
later stages the Fisher random Chess
Championship title is there for the
taking will you make a run at it go to F
our chests calm today to register and
stay tuned to chess comm for all the
latest news and updates regarding this
historic event
it's the feed a world Fisher random
chess let's remind everybody as we now
have both players back on camera that
this Friday that's today we have an
arena kings happening right after
today's show which is Fisher random and
that you can still sign up for the
Fisher random a World Chess Championship
qualifiers which are taking place every
Sunday your opportunity to try to play
and qualify for a world championship and
even if you don't make it to Oslo you
can compete in the title player portion
which starts right after the open
qualifiers Robert Hess he'll be he'll be
playing in or doing commentary with me
you don't even know what you're gonna be
doing that's what makes your life so
exciting right I feel like I've got this
mystery ahead of me and meet up with
both the same time wrote me and lastly
do common Channel rope you into both
well right now we've roped in about
8,500 of you still with us so thank you
for being here thank you for your
patience as we head into the one-minute
segment right now we've got Grandmaster
Wei Yi Grandmaster pregnant
a four-game lead right now for the one
seed in the junior speech his
championship Robert what does Prague
gotta do to find himself here just
convert on some of these winning
positions he had or you feel any other
magic recipe in the fastest time control
yes and move quickly in the early stages
in the game that sounds obvious in a
bullet portion but I've been saying this
in even the five minute segment I think
in the three minute segments he'd let it
go a little bit he spent way too much
time early in the game and he's just
trusts himself more right perfectionist
I know this full well didn't you always
call me out on it and correctly so then
I turned from the perfect move instead
of finding a good move that also saves
me time on the clocks I think frog has a
legitimate chance here especially way
he's connection continues to fail but
regardless of the connection I think
that Rob has a very good shot because
he's shown when there are seconds left
in the clock he's flagged progress
flagged when he three times and there
was connection well again if you're
watching this at chess comm or your home
page again click on the player and come
follow the twitch.tv slash chess channel
that purple button because right now the
bullet is getting underway the most
exciting segment we have in these
formats here we go the players are set
the games have started I have a feeling
this is this is gonna be something
something down the stretch here that
keeps us on the edge of our Syrah burn
like you said this is now slip b6 100%
of mouseland
must be already right and there you go
and like I don't even know why just like
given the tempo of this match we've seen
runs happen for both players if you're
just joining us and I don't think this
is gonna be a runaway victory for way
even though he has a four-game lead
right now call me crazy just don't call
me Shirley here we go well Shirley
you're crazy but Bishop c4 Bishop d3
Bishop d3
he's just getting defensive and that's
actually a strategy I don't like yeah
frustum sophomore Bishop c4 was
obviously a better move attacking the
pawn f7 ultra defensive I mean it's a
cringe-worthy Buddhist move especially
for our sponsor Cheska calm you tell
kids don't put your pieces in front of
your pawns like that a hundred percent
this just didn't seem like the most
aggressive thing that Y could do he will
Castle and his hope is that if if flack
takes everything he's gonna have rook e1
at the end of the line
start with really want yeah I think you
should work if one night takes F oh you
could take with the pawn there you go
rookie one look at that Oh miss is it
now 94 you can't play a three without
Bishop c5 coming yeah that's a mistake
me Bishop b5 check here yep okay and if
c6 you still have all kinds of ways to
take advantage of the pin yeah d4
probably just okay so still should be a
good a good game for Prague but he's not
doing what you told him to do Robert
which is trust your instincts and play
fast and I think if he had he probably
would have played rook e1 a little bit
quicker right maybe trying to play too
too good a moves right now still
definitely based on how much time he's
using please trying to be a
perfectionist and I know that's full up
from my experience we just talked about
it but now if three is gonna win the
piece although way he's getting some
compensation for sure at route 64 you
couldn't take it because Bishop c5 would
have pinned the Queen he probably could
have taken action then taking on c5
anyway and just said oh yeah that would
have been a lot of pieces yeah but this
is smarter you know don't get into any
kind of dynamic imbalance here just
queasy for queen c4 of Queenie
five-year-old g3 she's getting passive
again yeah I think this is this is a
sign of like you said it's a little bit
lack of confidence here okay okay
there's several things you can do Knight
d5 not a bad not a bad move at all
that's good that's a d6 a7 trade
everything you have Bishop chief so no
Brooke Dixie four that's how you return
to favorite boys and girls that was
really nice III they're good for
routines at for Bishop g3 was winning on
the spot again Prague is finding tactics
but Denny's he's kind of still not
confident enough to just fully execute
right now we can smell it okay but
that's that's a victory you can you
smell what pregnant is cookin
come on Dena come back nah and that's
what I'm talking about right there
frogs winning this match you're gonna
call it gone right now you're gonna say
Prague neon it's gonna come back and win
this match down three games he's winning
this match okay we'll see I again I
think that not only is he find
more tactics than way he has been in the
critical moments today everyone if
you're just joining us
but overall despite the disadvantage on
the scoreboard Prague has seemed to just
play better chess and and if he can if
he can stay out I stay out of blunders
and time scrambles I mean this is way
you hit way he has not been the dominant
player that you would expect him to be
in this match so far yeah and this
doesn't look good for for black though I
spoke too soon is about for coming down
well we have 26 minutes left in the
match a three game lead currently for
the top seed still has match to get
despite our sort of observations that
that the you know the score could be
different so Jeffrey Jones playing
Jeffrey Zhong is playing guess the move
right now and he was 6 of 6 in the last
one if you don't know what guess the
move is on chess comm you should it's a
lot of fun and Jeffrey Zhang is a very
strong grandmaster playing in the junior
speeches championship who's who's also
just having a good time trying to guess
these players moves yep and it's hard to
guess all of them that's for sure but
right now Prague is coming up with a
very traditional setup he's down upon on
the Queen side so he's giving himself
this pawn chain f7 age 5 the f7 is not
that easy of attack you can always like
rook d6 to f6 which an active way of
protecting the apologies and he's going
for that yeah it's a very smart just set
up there and also have you trade the
Queen's off the board white actually
might be closer to a draw than a win
because in a lot of these end games
where you have a two-on-one on the Queen
side that's your only advantage black
can stop it and just prevent you from
getting our troop at spawn so here do
you keep the Queen's on the board or
just simplify I mean probably you can
take and play Brooke f5 and you're still
in good chances to draw this also works
wasn't the eight pointing okay
Queens a5 I thought it was a free bond
but I think you're right these guys are
both a little bit silly right now but
they're so concentrating like the bigger
picture yeah use some of the granular
detail I'm in this case the pawn a5 was
just hanging 1/8 for here good move now
if you go beef we trade pawns but again
one pong and it's upon it's easily
blockaded so I like okay that's actually
a good decision okay now this should be
should be a clear a clear path to
drawing but g5 play g5 no G files you
create this chance for an outside pass
or with HP like I like I love it
King g6 rh4 first only a matter of age
Ford's good move rook g4 take it for gh4
and that rook on g4 so strong it
protects a four it keeps h4 safe and now
this is six q g5 king up bring that King
up B for takeoff hassan go Kings UK but
still should be a draw right we see
where you talking about Fischer random
they're good a good reminder to
everybody he likes to play it as well
alright but this should still be a job
rook up for he's threatening to play
King g5 and kimchi for with h3 getting
the rook out of the path of the king
Geoffrey John by the way it goes so with
Geoffrey how much money to play a game
with you he goes zero usually the rook
and h3 is stuck yep PHX yeah you check
it if the King if the King goes too far
you go right back normally and sort of a
frontal attack defense the rook can
swing and defend the pawn but that's not
possible here so should just be a pretty
straight forward draw now it's weight
using gamesmanship here does he know
it's a draw but is he milking time off
the total clock I think he is yeah I
think he understands that from a
practical point of view remember the
speech Chess Championship you're also
playing against that clock that's
ticking away and okay it does end in a
draw but but you get a lot of time off
the clock we now have 22 minutes left
and still a three game lead for the
Chinese Grandmaster
that was good defense there very good
defense by Prague mound down upon just
hell without too much effort honestly
thank you five I love this line
just just cackle kingside just cackle
kingside do it see this is a moment when
you spending what eight seconds or
something on this movie no I always yeah
it's been eight seconds of them move
just move you got a play got a play
faster right but isn't black just kind
of a huge trouble here 96
this is 96 this is a well-known idea the
point is if pawn takes you have Queen h5
check and you win back your place you
know you take on h6 first and you Queens
five and you f4 and you just made the
King 96 here's a moment where maybe it's
okay to take your time but overall
Prague has definitely been spending too
much time but he doesn't even go for it
I think you have to play for 96 so just
like the right decision and now this is
we're getting a normal line somehow we
transpose do in normal position oh man
he's not trusting himself it's been
known throughout it's definitely
definitely a bit of an experience
leading to some lack of confidence he's
still got a good position yep you know
to play Knight g3 is in a c3 but this is
okay well yeah that's a trap for kids
there's 96 maneuver it's like yeah very
good trap that's a that's a chess
kit.com video coming your way from fun
master Mike from today's from today's
match for sure
so two bishops for black but white has
the better puncture with the c6 bond fan
a little bit vulnerable but that said
the Queen side is locked down the
mission before is excellent the e4 pawn
is also feeling a little bit unsafe make
g3 for sure just put the nine g3 just do
it he's gonna do it and you do it there
it is
he spent six seconds and movie should
play into so it's really showing a lack
of experience and okay that makes sense
he's how old again 14 15 years old yeah
I'm not sure to be overly harsh about
his play but wait there should be six
oneexchange they should be six just one
the exchange they're just he's just he's
not he's not looking for his chances to
win right now he's I mean missing
ninety-six Bishop e6 was a one move
the exchange on the board yep and this
looks bad for white now because now the
bishop air has found itself but the e2
Knights hang the eat you know he's just
blundering pieces at the end of the
lines yeah go get some pawns he's not
actually he's got some chances here some
drawing chances hey take a five for the
C pawn Srivastav C pawn is just too much
yeah I mean you can't even play Brooks
e5 because they ate four pawn would have
fallen and now Charlie wait h7 same take
on h7 stricken take on h7 and threatened
rook AJ but still then King g8 it
doesn't matter you c3 g4 c4 yeah so now
this is also just an experience from a
match strategy point of view he's
playing this out out of frustration but
he has to realize this is not over yet
they took off another 45 seconds
honestly in terms of total total batch
game time oh my gosh she's 13 years old
oh wow I thought it was like 15 you know
how sometimes young chess players stay
young forever yeah people always think
that certain great Robson was 14 years
old first at least right and what he
became a grandmaster yeah and I just
lose track of time and I always think
people need a little bit older because
of that but anyway right now it with the
black pieces Prague has position that I
hate to see even the black side there's
you go fishing east 7 you always to be
careful Bishop f6 and d6 pawn just
falling not to mention the d5 square is
forever weakness and these kind of
structures I don't really believe in in
bullet chess I think just you're so
worried about all of the weak squares
it's hard to play quickly yeah and
especially in a situation where you're
already in must-win territory this is a
really tough position to generate things
as black unless white gives it to you
and that and that's the problem is white
is kind of in control of of the
different direction we see a lot of
people chatting in the game chat as well
Geoffrey Zhong asked who he thinks his
toughest opponent is to win the entire
juniors features championship but he
said don't forget cerana his first-round
opponent right he's not overlooking his
first-round opponent which is the right
answer right really really focused on
taking it one match at a time so
Jeffrey Zhang maybe thinking about
jumping into the Fisher random arena
today actually I seen a lot of
discussion going on him and Yan upon me
on chess calm might be playing in that
after today's show so stay tuned for
that but all right this is just this is
getting rough and and again this is not
gonna be when you look back on and feel
like it was a dominant affair start to
finish by the one seed people who missed
the match look at the scoreboard and say
well that's what we thought would happen
right but this was not without
opportunities and I'm not saying it's
over yet but it feels like prong the
Nanda is just tilting himself a little
bit and if this one Falls which looks
like it's about he's getting crushed
here the knight takes f6 oh it hurts
rook takes c8 and it's mate okay not
quite but you you know you get it I
exaggerate but you know might as well be
okay one or something like that
yeah and it's it's a lot of problems you
lose it a piece on F a game over Red
Rover me and and we do have made those
Knights
those are nice to remember are we in are
we in that at that time period where
it's almost mathematically impossible
unfortunately a five-game deficit the
comeback starts now or I'll call it it's
over it's looking pretty over Prague
wins this game or it's mathematically
right now it just seems to like like an
open-and-shut case
yep because as long as the games take a
while there's no risk for way easily
fraud has to win an ass when right now
just gotta get this one we see repeat of
one of the games from the 2018 World
Chess Championship
not exactly anymore but we were on that
path there a special knock off played
between Fabiano Caruana and magnus
carlsen kind of coming back right people
been shameless in there you know playing
special comp again and this is looking
like it's all the rage these days where
in this particular position why would
love to hold the center but Bishop a5
906 combination or just Queen e8 no
prima who that's also a pretty
aggressive move but Bishop before helps
this okay so this is I
Prague is holding the light squares here
now you want to get aggressive you have
place c4 develop your bishop go for c5
this actually looks way better than I
thought it was gonna look for white here
yeah I agree
again but time has been has been part of
the issue now yep
time is of the essence despite how he
handled time scrambles earlier in the
match a lot of stats now being given to
us saying that way he has played a lot
more bullet games on chess calm than
Prague and Honda including holding his
own against guys like Daniel narrowed
its key at times and clearly to start
this bullet portion he was above 3000
and now he's back above 3000 so I guess
experience suggested that way he would
be the better player in bullet even
though we saw Prague really hold his own
and some of the times grapples earlier
yeah wait he's just the superstar and
right now Prague is down 18 seconds 19
seconds 20 seconds keep counting he's
got to take on g4 play Brooke f3h I go
h3 and hold a position like that but
doesn't look Pleasant yeah this one
Falls I think the house crumbles with it
g3 unexpected moves not a good sign when
you have to play that move though
although actually might be good because
yeah it does swing the rook over to g2
and guard HT oh that's why you spend his
time there yeah and White's just a
couple moves away from playing c5 and
getting you Brooke g2 now you're
threatening to take okay yeah three but
that pawns gonna be corralled yeah
Queens g4 in that rook c2 they're
protected snorting c4 if efore c5 it's a
race I like this for white take a seven
takes a seven now you got to trust your
instincts and just go you've lost a pawn
just straight up one yeah II for just
loses the four pawn ouch town okay he's
gonna try to swing the rook for counter
play but whoa rookie how do you defend
that you engage for castle gauge for and
I've gotta move your rook now yeah okay
still still pretty tricky so I play
Brooke c3 and go corral the pawn but no
Prague what's counter play instead
probably is gonna Queen this one yeah
like dub c6 just go okay here you go
here comes the lady if you take g4 you
just take with the King on it three yeah
it's over seems you do and your king is
safe and there goes to see pong
okay well it's not over yet right
the fat lady is not singing a victory
there by prog Nenana we are not out of
the realm of a possibility I think it
has to or in must-win territory though I
think Brogdon Honda has to keep winning
every game from here on out yeah not not
a huge fan of these classical choice
okay well that helps I mean way you're
not going for the crazy theory I mean
personally I love the theory of the
rouser for white but you know that yeah
I do you do love that and right now it's
a solid setup from blacking one maneuver
your pieces to more useful squares your
setup is perfect pristine everything is
protecting each other no weaknesses to
speak up 95 going for an image of c4
that's very comedy of b5 of course you
can play as well no the knight has
vacated the c3 square he takes the
Knights gonna come to c4 yep actually
kind of irritating you can't really deal
with that that easy I like that g4 traps
a piece so that was terrible nevermind I
don't like that okay that could be it
is that it c4 threatened room 64 it's
not over yet oh he doesn't find it
I guess introversive where's Bishop e3
maybe but this is this is looking tough
whoa be to pawn under fire and play b6
at five can the adventurers stop make
some vision before stuff
this looks this is a trouble yeah the
pieces pieces of peace as they say
Bishop h3 right now it's just oh it
still goes from age three okay but now
black can play Bishop e5 and f4 alright
he's you know if you trade be 4a this
isn't that easy I guess I agree
so f4 - blade
so before it stops at four and protects
a fourth us it could move but somehow
this feels like it's not going the way
that way you wanted to yeah no I agree
this isn't hasn't been the cleanest
technique despite the blunder by
pregnant I I mean I think we're in
mathematical territory here everyone
with ten minutes left
fraud can't see this match go back to
five games and expect to come back it's
got it got to be another win here for
black which seems crazy to say right now
he should just lose down a piece a piece
for two pawns oh yeah he's winning
chances do not feel realistic here but
Jake's f2 and then Bishop e6 kingi okay
never mind
take on D form with Bishop d2 oh that
was doesn't it again you take d4 and
play Bishop - D - okay wait doesn't let
it happen a second time
yeah it's getting harder for a black to
come up with moves okay now you can play
for Bishop d2 you know tg6 mr. Kings
King gauge for there's Bishop e1 check
I mean after it came she's six oh yeah
okay look at this whoa bring it around
this is really smart and really tough
from white to meet in touch him nice for
threatening h3 and Bishop e3 e3 now yeah
how do you deal with f4 and Roque one
rookie - now easy okay - the ax for
pawns falling GG 6 just move the King
out ha no that was a patient should have
played king g6 Robert you're right he's
gonna win - b7 pawn but yeah he could
have taken on b7 there there was no mate
I think he I think if he if he keeps the
tension there he might even come back
and win that game draw whoa king of six
wonder who's the piece oh gosh who's the
D pawn 53 oh my gosh
g58 black can win this game yeah this is
a huge blunder one he's gonna lose
though he's down on time GG 4300 just
like what though Tigers do he turns
around it looks he's like did nobody
else see that I'm all alone
that is a game that Brogdon Honda had no
business winning whoa I felt myself
losing something energy because we're so
I'm gonna come back I know when the
comeback was nearing its end and now
it's still back on at full dinner he
literally just want an impossible game
to win so if you're talking about
comebacks eight minutes left with only
three minutes remaining
the one bad thing is about six seven
minutes went off the clock there I think
that was a long game what do you got
buddy one that's all that matters that
was unreal Queen b6 is a big threat we
b6 okay so turns it around
well 8,000 of you still with us
don't go anywhere the comeback is alive
this match is not over if you're
watching this at chess calm on your
homepage click on the player and go over
to twitch and give us a follow if you're
watching this at chess comm TV you
already know I love you know I just said
it I don't know I like I like to send my
kids text message all the time to say if
you're reading this text you already
know dot dot dot and then I say
something random mission b6 okay there's
a threat of Queen e8 okay he stops it
92d to keep the tension cuz if the
Knights on b3 a fives a weakness
shout out to midnight rhino for the bits
there thank you to everyone who's here
we've had a lot of love during today's
show we appreciate it
Queen B 1 the a4 pawn Falls it actually
actually that looks like a really ok
that's actually really good for will you
you know Queen B 1 C with an item b1 but
the knight c4 and nothing great but you
got to do this
tags you gotta take with the night to
hold the a pawn Knight c4 b3 I guess
black is not getting anything concrete
yeah actually I think White's gonna win
this game
really yeah see for you oh he had c4 now
you got to be careful about a past a
pawn just King f1 just bring the king in
he's spending a lot of time and that's
you would feel like if he had just
played king of one it would have been
the better move and the move you could
play faster right yeah play c4 c4 there
it is
c4 the night comes to b3 at some point
eight five falls in place c5 yeah I
think he could have played c5 but he
maybe he wants this night b3 idea I'm
talking about bring the king to c3 and
night b3 he definitely does whoa
three play f3 and stop the counter play
no one misses it he's gonna like miss 94
check before and g4 that was a big
mistake because now bus 94 check now now
now f3 actually came in time I mean
every would have been the more accurate
move but Prague is actually in control
yet again well this looks really tough
for black because when White's the
newest addition eetu do like attack this
g4 bond and then force you to make a
decision with that would you be to just
fight quickly play Bishop e2 sit on the
position Black has no moves okay this is
where Prague might let the game game
slip right okay now he finds it but have
to play a little faster 91 95 even are
you winning the are you winning the
endgame if the King gets in he finds it
what is happening here King d4 and king
e5 usual king of six so I'm stuck g3 is
a draw g3 yeah but now you can take
everything on g4 wait
they keep both are missing it g3 here is
the draw okay nevermind i c5 was no good
I was wrong and that's actually you were
right dude he should have taken on g4
there yeah but that's a huge game
because Prague settling on a draw here
is settling on okay I mean four minutes
and three games the fat lady is about to
sing and when she comes out I will be
using my voice I don't know why I said
that but there you go car would shuffle
the bishop around forever as why you
just won the match
yeah you would have just won the match
with Bishop Bishop Bishop shuffle puck
thanks only shook did that at some point
chris scherk did do that and I think
Magnus did that in a match too he was he
was up against Hikaru and there and
their speeches championship final in
2017 I think but we've seen a lot of
people use the gamesmanship that you see
in I always refer to the NBA when you
think about it especially because
Toronto won last night shout out to the
Raptors and my boy Drake Haskell see how
come an amazing game yeah but yeah you
think of it kind of like dribbling out
the clock as they say something that the
speech yes championship format has okay
he finds Quinn a five the second game
around I'm I hate to say it Robert but I
think that game decided it I think his
inability to put that one away
yeah Prague Prague seems like a young
man who's kind of settled on the fact
that he had a good match maybe he didn't
expect to win but from our perspective
this was right there for him to grab
totally he has been playing a good match
he's gotten himself in these moments
where he just hesitant I am very curious
to ask him about that if he sort of felt
like he had to find extremely precise
moves at all times but I think he lets
certain games slip because of how much
time you spent in clearly this game I
mean he's out 12 seconds on the clock
right now right well either way those
questions and more will be asked to the
players so if you're with us don't go
anywhere after the one-minute portion
regardless of what happens we will
interview these two young gentlemen and
get their thoughts on how the match won
be five nice counter-attack mm-hmm
something tells me we knows he's got it
now
yeah that's not just the blue shirt
talking to me I do like that shirt it is
it's got style what's this the nice
protected right there's c4 oh okay your
capture mode wait time is ticking Najee
six just go at four no thinking I love
it which is a great move no even sack
the exchange here and play Bishop the
uneven care Bishop d4 you have to do
something
b5
oh he's doing the reset take he didn't
follow this before
okay I don't know if way you remember
the Queen was guarding that square I
don't know what's going on but how many
pauses well I have three pawns not
enough though a lot of time is gonna
come off the clock here less than two
minutes with a three game lead and
probably probably no chances that he
loses this one Prague na na na na na na
Wei Wei Yi goodbye well done Prague
nanananana Wei Wei Yi goodbye the match
is over prog none and non Anand
Wei Wei Yi goodbye let me hear you that
was actually one forget you as me he
bends over and he blended that and with
that they will play one more game their
swan song to bring this match to a close
I will not sing anymore so don't worry
don't worry all of you I love this
coming Daniel let me give you some
advice don't sing on stream hey I've
heard that advice a lot I thought have I
ever taken good advice yes yeah okay but
not all the time it hasn't been since
like 2012 yep it'll go on my grapes
don't always listen to the advice from
twitch chat exactly if people don't get
sarcasm there I don't know what will
what's on h6 doing hey where'd he go
treated never mind
chess is confusing Danny it is confusing
well time is officially running out this
is the last game worth probably worth
though about 75 to 100 bucks though
right I mean that's the way these
matches work prizes are split up based
on the winner and then win percentage
looks like the final score is not going
to be exactly what smarter chefs
predicted but shout out to Matt Jensen
who inspired me for that little tune
there but also inspires us with our
predictions all the time and he he was
right that way II was the heavy favorite
thanks Captain Obvious but I think this
match I think this match really could
have gone either way if Prague had a
little more experience at a little more
confidence absolutely agree with that I
thought probably put some really good
games he showed that he can compete when
the clock gets low but unfortunate for
him I really think comes out of him
having a lack of experience and that's
because he's 13 years old so we forgive
him for that I think next time around
he'll be even more of a formidable
opponent because he just needs to be
less of a perfectionist in these yep
blitz games and just trust himself
because he's such a fantastic player
yeah great advice coming from one of the
greatest coaches I know
Grand Master Robert Hess when is your
next coaching affair are you coaching
the US women's Olympia team again do you
know yet
you never know and so right beforehand
so it's the players select the coach oh
yeah that's right depends so wonder you
keep getting selected because because
you do a great job no seriously I think
you're right is great advice and I think
for Prague his coaches will be telling
him the same thing but super talent and
that's why we're doing the juniors
features championship and remember
Robert you and I were covering the world
championship in November when we asked
the fans what would you like to see
about the SCC and we had suggestions
about doing a women's in juniors event
and so thank you to everybody who
answers our questions on social media
uses the hashtag speech s and gets
involved because we clearly do listen
and and try to do things and I think
this juniors speeches champion match is
going to be a ton of fun for the next
couple months
absolutely and Queen FA it looks fun for
white here as probably genius going down
in the last game so a slight kind of
moral victory that victory there for
Prague who finished
is losing the match by a score of three
games we're gonna come back here in just
a few moments with interviews with the
players to wrap up the junior speeches
championship for today brought to you by
chest kid comm don't go anywhere I'm
watching you we'll be right back
[Music]
and we are now joined by both of our
very very talented chess players here
grandmaster Wei Yi and prog Nenana here
from India guys first of all thank you
both so much
this was this was a great match full of
full of back and forth little runs by
both you guys prog went when you tied
the match up at 5 games apiece there
what was going through your head at that
at that time in terms of thinking what
do you need to do to win this match okay
just keep going just keep playing like
this and try to do the best but the next
ki I was okay but I lost somehow then
yeah sound game was yeah
next game was very our stamina I just
been on this rope anyone how does that
how do you recover from the the
emotional setback there of wandering the
rock did you do you give yourself a pep
talk what goes through your head and
wondered what advice do you give
yourself after you maybe lose a game
that you know you had no business losing
yeah
prog question for you throughout the
match it felt like you were trying to
find the perfect move instead of
sometimes trying to find the fast move
do you feel like you were looking too
much to play the best chess possible
which is great for classical chess and
maybe sometimes struggle with keeping
your time management under control in
the opening stage then I lay my time but
the pea
I've done the beat up didn't or faster
way Yee congrat congratulations on on
winning the match and moving on to the
next round
what do you feel was was the key today
the match had a lot of streaks where it
seemed like you were building a lead and
because you're the one seed maybe people
thought you were gonna run away with it
but but you couldn't quite keep the
rhythm going and it seemed like Prague
almost came back many times so how are
you handling those moments where you
lost a couple games in a row to help
yourself recover and and then win the
next game it was a difficult match and
my opponent mr. a lot of trust in the
three main scans and otherwise the
results will be contradicted and and I
saw too much in some positions that's
why a waste in sometimes trouble I lost
three games in a row five minutes game
yes yeah but it's not I still need to
play some good moves this way you've
lost three games on time during the
match did that make you nervous heading
towards the bulla session that maybe
your opponent would be able to catch up
even though you were up several games in
the match yeah I felt very nervous after
lost his three games then my opponent
mr.
Prague Prague do you feel that way that
this game that this match could have
gone the other way that there were
several games that you just did
convert one reason or another making a
blunder under time pressure or just
taking too much time do you do you feel
like in hindsight this could have gone
your way that was a important game but
still I got some lucky points like in
the trucking game VG got flat another
one was a net connection so yeah was I
mean we both I think I was I had a very
bad internet connection
yeah well there were not many draws in
this match there were actually only two
draws total what what do you think I'll
ask you about that why do you think
there weren't too many drawers with with
your particular style of play or waitwe
Yi why do you think there weren't so
many draws in this match very exciting
and we always lost in time lost on time
and draw on positions yeah what about
you speaking of time I have a question
for both you it's very late in both
India and China how was it challenging
for you to play at such a late hour or
are you like typical chess players who
stay up way too late anyway an hour
playing chance past midnight
no it's well sorry I cook about four
o'clock in China and it it is always
very nice to play just yes so it's not
too it's not too later
early for you to play good chess
apparently way that's very challenging
very challenging them now what about for
you Prague how early do you usually have
to go to bed be honest you're only 13
years old and you're up past your
bedtime right now so I have some there
was no problem playing this match got it
okay well honestly this was a great
match it was super exciting for all of
us and I know that I'm sure you both
have things to get to like sleep so I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna hold you up too
much longer besides thank you
congratulate you both and then leave you
wayy with one final question you're
playing Jordan Vaughn Far East in the
next round
you actually know your opponent well in
advance right Jordan obviously barely
got by our Yount Ari but what are your
thoughts Wei Yi on what you need to do
to beat Jordan Vaughn for East your East
that's that's who you're playing in the
next round yes they didn't like the
games yeah I will
okay so you will prepare okay good to
know
all right well we're gonna let you both
go Prague again congratulations on a
well-played match no it didn't go your
way but we we definitely look forward
you had a lot of fans here watching your
future early and wayy congratulations
for moving on to the next round and and
we will see you I think sometime in July
for your match vs Jordan Vaughn for East
bye guys let's let's remind everybody
Robert of our next matchup
it'll be Sam Semyon versus Niehaus Oran
right so the countryman here of Prague
Nevada taken on Sam seve on should be
pretty exciting on on June 3rd yeah
that's actually one of my favorite
matches of the entire event I think this
might be the one to keep your eye on
because Sam 7 he's lost his rating
near 2680 territory but neo Sauron is
the youngest 2600 in the world so
clearly a rising talent himself yep
absolutely and we'll see we'll see what
happens there I think that one is as
close to a coin flip as you can have I
agree let's talk about what's out coming
up tomorrow the chess kid games
obviously our sponsor is Cheska calm but
tomorrow is a huge event it'll be
commentated by video master Mike Klein
an international master David proved us
but here we've got some real kiddos some
real young juniors but they're also
pairing up with some stars that we've
seen kind of grow up on chess kid kids
that we've known since they were very
little who are coming back there now now
a whole bunch of title players look at
that list there you've got Hans Neiman
who many of you know you've got
Christopher you so so many very very
strong players Roland Fang they are
gonna be joining up and they will be
paired up with a very young kid like
like really really young and they're
gonna be going through a number of
different tasks they're on Cheska comm
so should be a blast to see what happens
when these title players who've been
using chess kids since they were easy
itty bitty babies do paired up with a
kid also let's remind you of the
schedule before you go anywhere mark
your calendar for our next speed chess
championship matchup that is as we said
June 3rd Sam Savion versus nihill Soren
we've got the reigning world junior
champion coming up after that Parham ugh
Sulu from iran versus the young italian
Moroney there also should be a great one
so mark your calendars and stay with it
now as we say goodbye Robert we're gonna
leave everybody with the moment of the
match I don't know what it is neither do
you it'll be fun and we're gonna be
sitting here watching it as we head to a
close so if you did clip something for
us and share it on social media we
really appreciate that for all those of
you that have been here for everyone
here behind the scenes at chest icon
making this happen thank you for being
here and enjoy the moment of the match
coming to you right now
Queen takes Queen rook takes h3 no Queen
eight green guards h4 bleonard no he
sees work f4 but kq7 you missed Queen
takes a four negative six check puzzle
rush me oh my gosh that would have been
nasty I will show it as soon as the game
is over don't go anywhere
there was puzzle rush meet there there
may still be some sort of puzzle rush
you miss queeny one there
Brogdon honda has tied the match let me
show you oh my let me show you what just
happened
it's this position crazy but it wasn't
was it made Queen takes up 409 f6 check
and you bring the other work into d8 yes
oh my gosh that would have been so nasty